[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct.
André Merlin, bonsoir. Vincent de la
bonsoir André si vous voulez bien vous
présenter.
Écoutez, je suis d'abord né dans un
petit pays qui est au confin de la Corè
et du Cantal, la haute vallée de la
Dordogne. Euh ça s'appelle la Xintie
pour ceux qui connaissent un petit peu.
Je suis issu d'une lignée
de Forgeron Maréchal Ferrand et j'ai été
le premier de cette lignée à quitter le
pays pour comment on dit monter à Paris
et exercer faire des études supérieures
et ensuite exercer mon métier
d'ingénieur. Voilà. Et vous êtes
fondateur de pardon ? Vous êtes
fondateur de Alors, je suis fondateur
bien évidemment de RTE euh bien après
euh que j'ai passé j'ai passé plusieurs
années d'abord à la recherche à EDF puis
ensuite dans des directions
opérationnelles et en 2000 euh suite à
l'adoption de la directive européenne
sur l'ouverture des marchés, le ministre
en charge de l'énergie m'a demandé
effectivement de prendre la direction de
RTE, ce que j'ai fait pendant 7 ans.
C'est quoi RTE ? Alors RTE, c'est le
gestionnaire du réseau de transport
d'électricité.
C'est lui qui d'une
part construit
exploite le réseau de transport
d'électricité, c'est-à-dire les les
autoroutes
électriques, les routes nationales et
même les routes départementales. C'est
c'est un très grand réseau qui s'est
construit au fil des années. et puis
c'est lui aussi qui
organise en quelque sorte l'équilibre
entre l'offre, la production
d'électricité et la demande, c'est la
consommation. Donc c'est le c'est le
vraiment le point central dans le
fonctionnement du système électrique
français. C'est le système nerveux.
Vincent de la est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bien sûr,
je vais essayer de le faire. J'ai moi
j'ai fait une école de commerce, pas
d'ingénieur, je suis désolé. Personne
n'est parfait mais personne n'est
parfait. J'ai fait les secs et j'ai
commencé ma carrière professionnelle
dans la banque et ensuite dans l'audit.
Donc je suis un homme de chiffres hein
plutôt et j'ai travaillé 13 ans dans le
privé avant de me lancer en politique,
mon père m'avait donné le virus, il
était maire adjoint et je lui avais dit
moi si je me lance ça sera plutôt pour
être maire. Et donc j'ai commencé ma
carrière politique à Massie où on
habitait avec mon épouse, on a eu cinq
enfants et j'ai commencé par battre
Mélenchon. Ça a été un peu mon fait de
guerre en 92 des élections cortonales et
Mélenchon m'a aidé ensuite à prendre la
mairie puisquil il en voulait au maire
maire socialiste et j'ai pris la ville
de Massi qui était plutôt une ville de
gauche qui restait une ville de gauche
et j'y suis resté 22 ans. Mélanchon
pensait que j'y resterai 6 ans. Je suis
resté 22 ans. J'ai été président aussi
d'une communauté d'agglomération avec
toutes les communes autour et puis je
suis devenu sénateur il y a 14 ans et
j'ai intégré la commission des finances
puisque je suis un homme de chiffres.
J'aime bien j'aime bien tout ce qui
tourne autour des finances. Et puis je
me suis rendu compte qu'on avait peu
d'informations en tant que
parlementaire, contrairement à ce que
chacun peut croire et euh que ce qui
était vraiment très intéressant comme
outil au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale, c'est commission d'enquête.
Et donc, j'ai commencé à faire une
commission d'enquête en 2000 sur les
autoroutes, les autoroutes historiques,
les concessions historiques d'autoroute.
Et donc, je me suis bien éclaté dans
cette commission d'enquête. Ça faisait
la synthèse entre ce que j'avais fait
dans le privé et ce que j'avais fait
comme en public dans le politique. Et et
puis ensuite l'année dernière, j'ai j'ai
décidé de lancer une commission
d'enquête sur l'électricité parce que je
me posais des questions à la fois sur
les prix qui s'envolaient et sur la
capacité de la France à faire face à la
demande puisque on disait il faut tout
électrifier, comment va-t-on faire alors
queon avait laissé un peu tomber, on a
même laissé largement tomber toute la
partie nucléaire qui était la base et le
socle de notre production électrique.
Donc voilà, j'ai j'ai travaillé sur ce
sujet-là et puis en ce moment, je suis
aussi en train de travailler sur l'aide
médicale d'état puisque je suis
rapporteur de la mission santé. L'aide
médicale d'État, vous savez, c'est c'est
l'aide qui est donnée quoi. C'est c'est
ce qui permet de couvrir en santé les
personnes en situation irrégulière, les
étrangers en situation régulière en
France. Donc c'est un sujet assez
politique et pas facile. On est très
content de vous avoir tous les deux ce
soir. On va bénéficier de vos jus de
cerveau à la fois avec monsieur Merlin
avec sa longue expérience des autoroutes
de l'électricité et avec monsieur le
sénateur à la suite de la commission
d'enquête. Première question, on va
donner la parole à monsieur
Merlin. Ça se passe bien en Espagne
l'électricité. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
? Alors, l'Espagne c'est non seulement
l'Espagne mais le Portugal, hein. Il y a
eu effectivement le 28 avril un ce qu'on
appelle un blackout, c'est-à-dire un
effondrement complet du système
électrique. Tous tout le monde s'est
retrouvé dans le noir en l'espace de
quelques secondes. Tout s'est arrêté,
les métros, les trains, euh les
aéroports, les aéroports étaient
bloqués. Il y avait également les
hôpitaux qui étaient privés
d'électricité. Alors, ils avaient des
groupes électrogènes, ça s'est pas trop
mal passé. Les communications ont été
également
perturbées et effectivement ce qu'on
appelle effectivement la plus
grave situation qu'on peut rencontrer au
niveau d'un d'un grand réseau électrique
à interconnecté. Alors, on a entendu
dire que c'était un hack des Russes, que
c'était un cyber hacking, que c'était
une mouette qui avait cramé dans un
transf. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
monsieur Merlin ? Alors, on a eu très
peu d'informations et aujourd'hui
encore, on a assez peu d'informations
venant des gestionnaires de réseau de
transport d'électricité du de l'Espagne
et de
Portugal, mais on a quand même le
l'enchaînement de tous les événements
qui se sont produits jusque à
l'effondrement du système électrique.
est compte la connaissance que j'ai
quand du sujet, j'ai vécu plusieurs
blackout en France et en Europe ou je
pourrais y revenir si vous avez des
questions. Ce que je pense, c'est
qu'effectivement il y a eu beaucoup trop
d'électricité
d'origine
solaire et un degré moindre d'origine
éolienne pour satisfaire la demande
d'électricité du de l'Espagne et du
Portugal.
Et malheureusement, c'est un
inconvénient pour ces ces énergies,
c'est qu'elles ne sont pas pilotable et
qui plus elles ne contribuent pas du
tout à la stabilité du système
électrique interconnecté.
Donc ce qui s'est passé, c'est que on a
vu apparaître une
instabilité au niveau de la péninsule
ibérique dès le début de la matinée vers
9h et cette instabilité progressivement
s'est accru à mesure d'ailleurs que la
part de la production d'électricité
d'origine solaire augmentait parce que
le pic de la production se situe
effectivement en plein milieu de
journée, hein, c'est clair. Et justement
vers
12h30, on a on a observé plusieurs
déconnexion de central solaires
espagnoles automatiqu automatique
effectivement qui ont accru encore
l'instabilité du système ibérique et à
12h
33 il y a eu une déconnexion
automatique du des réseaux ibériques par
rapport au réseaux européen, c'estàdire
ouverture des interconnexions
électriques entre la France et
l'Espagne. Il y a une protection qu'on
appelle une protection à rupture de
synchronisme. Pourquoi ? Parce que les
deux systèmes, celuique et le français
étaient désynchronisés en quelque sorte.
Et donc à partir de ce moment-là,
n'ayant plus le support du reste de
l'Europe, le système électrique ibérique
s'est effondré carrément en l'espace de
secondes. Alors, une fois que ce c'était
pas la mouette, c'est c'était peut-être
qu'il y avait une mouette quelque part,
c'est possible. Mais ce qui est
fondamental, c'est que le système
ibérique était devenu instable. Et
pourquoi il est devenu instable ? parce
que la pas la
proportion de d'électricité d'origine
solaire et un degré moins de éolienne
était trop importante. Ça a constitu à
peu près 70 %. Et de mon point de vue
d'ingénieur connaissant bien ce domaine,
on vous raconte pas de carabis tout. Je
considère Oui, je considère que si on
dépasse les 50 %, on prend un risque qui
me paraît excessif. Et d'ailleurs,
depuis qu'il y a eu ce ce blackout, ces
derniers jours, ils ont continué
effectivement à produire de
l'électricité à partir du solaire et de
l'éolien, et bien, ils ont réduit les
proportions de telle sorte de pas
retrouver cette instabilité. Ils nous le
diront, ils l'ont pas encore dit parce
que il y a bien évidemment derrière cela
un aspect très politique et il y a sans
doute une pression qui s'exerce sur les
ingénieurs qui s'occupent de ce domain.
Alors ça tombe bien, on a un politique
juste à votre gauche, monsieur Merlin.
On va pouvoir le mal mener ce soir. Mais
avant de lui donner la parole, on a
entendu très récemment que les Chinois
dans leur panneaux solaires, ils avaient
quand même caché un petit truc pour
provoquer de l'instabilité. Ouais. Ça
pourrait venir de ça ou pas ? Je pense
que c'est peu probable. Je c'est
possible hein, mais c'est c'est pas
probable. Moi, je pense plutôt que
effectivement les centrales solaires
produisent de l'électricité dite à
couron alors que l'électricité qui
circule sur notre réseau, sur tous les
réseaux européens d'ailleurs et ailleurs
dans le monde sont des des c'est
l'électricité à courant alternatif. Donc
il faut transformer le courant continu
produit par ces centrales solaires en
courant alternatif. C'est comment la
courbe du courant alternatif ? Vous
voulez nous la faire avec le doigt ?
Non, c'est 50 périodes par par seconde
50 Hz. F = 1/ T. Euh pardon ? F = 1/ T.
Oui. Oui, c'est ça. Oui, oui,
effectivement. Est-ce qu'on malmène un
peu notre politique ? Monsieur Merlin,
je vous donne la parole pour donner la
parole à monsieur le sénateur. Voilà.
Alors, que pensent les politiques ?
effectivement de cette situation. Ouais,
on aimerait bien y voir
clair. C'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un sujet qui a été abordé
assez souvent notamment dans la
commission d'enquête. hein. Moi, toutes
les personnes que j'ai rencontré m'ont
dit "Attention, il y a quand même un
risque." Si on augmente fortement euh
les énergies renouvelables
intermittentes et notamment le solaire,
il y a un risque sur le réseau et
technique. Alors moi, je suis un peu
débordé par cet aspect technique, mais
euh c'est vrai que c'est un sujet et on
aimerait bien que la clarté d'ailleurs
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres hein,
moi je dis que la transparence c'est à
la base de la démocratie. Donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on devrait avoir
systématiquement. Je pense qu'on va
finir par l'avoir à un moment donné,
mais je trouve que c'est un petit peu
long. C'est quand même un petit peu long
pour nous dire exactement si c'est la
mouette ou si c'est le solaire ou si
c'est les Chinois ou les Russes ou c'est
les Chinois ou les Russes. Voilà. Bon,
en question à un politique, quand vous
avez une commission d'enquête, euh vous
nous avez dit que vous nagiez un petit
peu sur l'aspect technique. Comment vous
faites pour comprendre ? Est-ce que vous
avez un carnet d'adresse qui vous permet
de vous bien vous faire conseiller ?
Est-ce que vous par exemple vous avez le
numéro de monsieur Merlin en lui disant
monsieur Merlin j'ai besoin d'un coup de
main parce que j'y comprends que dalle.
Vous savez, on a auditionné 150
personnes. Donc quand on auditionne 150
personnes, on cherche toutes toutes les
personnes qui ont un point de vue, qui
ont eu des responses responsabilités,
qui en ont encore, qui peuvent dire des
choses intéressantes et on rend compte,
on a bien sûr des auditions publiques,
c'est ce qu'on voit à la télé avec les
les auditionnés qui qui prêtent serment
pour de dire toute la vie, rien que la
vérité. Mais le plus le plus important
presque c'est les contacts qu'on peut
avoir euh directement qu le rapporteur
que j'étais parce que le rapporteur
c'est celui qui écrit le rapport hein.
Donc c'est celui qui à la fin avec les
administrateurs euh décide 700 pages 821
821 exactement. Donc je pense qu'on a on
n pas fait le tour complet du sujet
parce que c'est un sujet extrêmement
complexe et c'est vrai que même si on
n'est pas ingénieur, moi j'essaie de
comprendre hein. Bon, il y a des choses
que j'arrive quand même à comprendre
même si je comprends pas forcément tout
et surtout quand c'est bien expliqué.
Donc il y a des professionnels comme
André Marlin qui savent très bien
expliquer les choses. Le haut
commissaire aussi à l'énergie atomique
Vincent Berger qui est quelqu'un aussi
de très clair. Moi, je l'ai eu presque
pendant 2 heures en tête à tête et sans
sans avoir prêté serment et autres. Mais
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses et c'est
vrai qu'on apprend énormément de choses.
On recoupe, on lit aussi beaucoup de
choses et je fais un rapport juste avec
les autoroutes. Les autoroutes c'est
tombé en même temps
que que le confinement. Donc j'avais
tout mon temps. J'avais tout mon temps.
J'ai lu toute la littérature, tout ce
qui pouvait être écrit sur les
autoroutes, tous les rapports qui
avaient été faits, tout. Je connaissait
tout de A à Z quasiment. Et euh donc ça
tombe bien, on va essayer d'avoir
monsieur De Vilpin. On vous appellera
peut-être pour peut-être pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas ? Parce que c'est vrai que
il y a de quoi dire. Il y a de quoi dire
sur ce qui a été fait à l'époque, pas
forcément sur la privéation, sur le fait
de faire des concessions, mais surtout
de ne pas avoir modifié du tout les
contrats. On a des contrats qui sont
absolument pas adaptés à des
concessions, à des sociétés privées.
Moi, je suis pas contre la concession à
sociétés privées. Revenons sur
l'électricité. Votre rapport de plus de
800 pages, il y a eu une synthèse, une
conclusion qui fait 10 pages. Oui. Qui
est accessible pour tout le monde. Tout
à fait. D'ailleurs, comme l'émission va
durer plus d'une heure, je vous
conseille d'aller chercher les 10 pages
comme ça vous serez pas dépaysé.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit ces 10 pages ?
Alors si dit pas je vous rappelle le
point de départ quand même de c'était de
se dire est-ce qu'on risque un blackout
à un moment donné parce que
effectivement non non pas parce que
c'est c'est on met de l'électricité en
continu déjà préparé sa calnikov là non
pas du tout mais est-ce que est-ce qu'on
risque un blackout ou pas et est-ce que
finalement on a pris les dispositions
pour ne pour anticiper tout cela et puis
pourquoi on a des variations aussi
importantes du prix de l'électricité et
est-ce que on pourrait pas trouver
un mode qui permette d'avoir un prix
d'électricité plus stable, qui permett
quand même de financer des gros
investissements que c'est des
investissements lourds mais qui en même
temps soit accessible pour les
particuliers et qui soient compétitif
aussi pour les entreprises. Monsieur le
sénateur, vous donnez la parole à
monsieur Merlin quand vous voulez sur le
prix de l'électricité et le prix des
renouvelables. Monsieur Merlin, alors
alors le comment vous choisissez le bon
mix électrique, monsieur Merlin, le bon
mix électrique. La question
effectivement au travers de cela et et
on fera un lien d'ailleurs avec le
blackout de qui s'est produit sur la
péninsule ibérique, c'est quel est le
futur mix électrique pour la France pour
les 10 ans qui viennent et même au-delà
jusqu'en 2050.
Euh et euh ce que nous disons, enfin ce
que je dis en particulier, c'est que
d'abord on a euh une consommation
d'électricité qui euh a baissé depuis
2012, hein, et qui est au niveau
actuellement de 2003. Donc, il n'y a pas
urgence dans les médias à construire de
nouveaux moyens de production. Par
contre, du fait de la politique qui est
celle de l'Union européenne et qui
s'applique également à la France de
décarbonation, l'idée effectivement
c'est de basculer le maximum
d'application vers l'électricité,
l'application et donc on prévoit bien
évidemment une augmentation du prix du
volume d'électricité
consommé. Cette augmentation va être
très progressive. On le voit d'ailleurs
au niveau par exemple des véhicules
électriques, les objectifs qu'on avait
fixés au préalablement ne sont seront
pas atteints de même dans d'autres
domaines comme l'hydrogène. Donc ça
c'est la première chose. Le la
consommation d'électricité sera sans
doute moins élevée que certains le
pensaient il y a déjà 3 4 ans. Les
choses ont évolué. La deuxième chose,
c'est que on a un parc
nucléaire qui est hérité qui est hérité
donc de de de l'époque de Gérald de Gaul
et de de George Pompidou et de
Bernardbert et donc de Bernardbert qui
était leur conseil leur conseiller, on
l'embrasse. Voilà, il faut il faut le
souligner qui fonctionne très bien. Bien
évidemment, on a eu le problème de la
corrosion sous contrainte en 2022, mais
ceci est maintenant réglé. Et donc on
peut compter sur un parc nucléaire qui
non seulement a une bonne disponibilité
et qui plus euh produit de l'électricité
à un prix le plus bas d'Europe avec
l'hydraulique qui est qui est produit en
particulier dans le dans le dans les
pays dans en Norvège et et en Suède.
Donc ça c'est le deuxième chose. Et donc
la question qui se pose c'est quelle est
la quantité de renouvelable intermittent
que l'on doit ajouter à ce mix
électrique ? Et nous considérons que la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
telle qu'elle est proposée actuellement
par les pouvoirs public va beaucoup trop
loin dans le développement des énergies
renouvelables intermittentes. Alors la
conséquence c'est que ces énergies
renouvelables intermittentes sont
subventionnées en grand règle générale.
De combien de pourcent ? Bah je vais
vous donner un exemple très simple. On
construit un parc éolien au
chor et ce parc éolien au chor euh on le
fait l'objet d'un appel d'offre qui
conduit effectivement l'État à
garantir un prix fixe sur 20
ans qui est actuellement est de l'ordre
de 200 € du
MWh. 200 € du MW comparé au prix du
marché qui est actuellement monsieur le
sénateur de 35 et 25 € enfin peut-être
un peu plus
mais ce soir j'ai regardé c'est 15 ou
oui avec effectivement actuellement oui
il y a des moments négatif ou pas non
alors j'en viendrai après au prix
négatif mais si vous voulez donc la
différence entre le prix fixé dans le
contrat garanti par l'État et le prix de
marché, c'est des subventions qui sont
accordées par les pouvoirs
publics. Par les pouvoirs publics et qui
figure soit sur le budget de l'État,
donc qui creusent la dette ou bien sont
se traduisent par des taxes
supplémentaires pour les consommateurs
et notamment les consommateurs
domestiques.
Et tel que c'est parti, je prévois ça ça
peut se discuter, mais que d'ici 10 ans,
si on applique effectivement la PPE
telle qu'elle est proposée, c'est un
doublement du prix de l'électricité pour
les consommateurs domestiques. On est
actuellement à 200 € du MWh. 1 MWh,
c'est 1000
kWh. Et ce que je pense, c'est on va
passer à 400. C'est quoi votre source
pour les 200 € ? Alors, les 200 € c'est
le résultat des appels d'offre qui ont
été euh déjà accordés pour les six parc
éolien offshore de Normandie et de
Bretagne. Et au niveau
international, le
euh le plus gros groupe industriel qui
produit des qui construit des
éoliennes indique qu'actuellement c'est
de l'ordre de 230 € 230 dollars par MWh.
Donc on est à peu près à 200 € et avec
l'inconvénient en France d'avoir des des
des rivages
qui au fur à mesure qu'on qu'on s'écarte
de la côte deviennent de plus en plus
profond le le fond de la et donc plus
c'est profond plus ça coûte hein
puisqu'il faut ancrer en quelque sorte
ces éoliennes dans le fond de la mer. Ça
suppose d'ailleurs des une quantité de
béton énorme et comme on pourra pas
aller trop trop loin, on imagine en plus
dans le futur d'avoir des éoliennes
flottantes technologiques. Je sais pas
si vous partagez ce point de vue qui
n'est pas encore mature et qui va coûter
encore plus cher si vous voulez. Et donc
sur le budget d'État, je considère que
d'ici 10 ans, si on n'y prend pas garde
et si on applique le programme de la la
PPE, c'est de l'ordre de 2000 MW
d'éolien
euh marin chaque année, hein. De deux
parcs éolien de 1000 MW, on peut le
dire.
éolien MW et bien ce sera une charge
annuelle de 10 milliards d'euros pour le
budget de l'État ou si c'est pas sur le
budget d'État, ça va se traduire par une
augmentation des tarifs pour les
consommateurs domestiques. Une paille,
une paille. Monsieur Merlin, est-ce que
vous avez une question à poser à
monsieur le sénateur ?
Pardon ? Une question pour monsieur le
sénateur. Pas de question mais je vais
quand même y répondre. Alors répondez-y
s'il y a pas de question. Mais non mais
je pense qu' il faut par rapport aux
personnes qui nous écoutent aussi redire
bien bon d'abord que l'énergie c'est
fondamental que l'énergie en France la
principale énergie qu'on consomme elle
est importée hein c'est les énergies
fossiles puisque l'électricité ça
représente entre 25 et 25 % de à peu
près la consommation énergétique et que
c'est il y a que l'électricité qu'on
arrive à produire en France he on
produit pas de pétrole produit de la
dette et des vieux paraît-il.
Mais euh honnêtement donc il il faut il
faut s'interroger sur la façon dont on
peut produire plus d'électricité. Bien
sûr qu' comment on peut électrifier nos
usages hein ? Quand on dit électrifier
les usages, c'estàd transformer sur les
transports, sur l'industrie, sur le
bâtiment, tout ce qu'on peut faire pour
favoriser la consommation électrique et
après quelle est la le meilleur mixte
électrique qu'on peut qu'on peut avoir ?
Et comme on n pas de l'argent à l'infini
non plus, ça vous le savez très bien,
expliquer à monsieur le président,
faudra expliquer peut-être à tout le
monde peut-être. Moi, j'ai j'ai écrit
j'ai écrit un livre les vertus de
l'équilibre ou l'antiqua qui en coûte.
L'antiqua qui l'en coûte, vous pouvez le
prendre et c'était en 2020, je l'ai
écrit et donc moi j'étais absolument pas
pour quoi qu'il en coûte et c'est
préfacé par Bruno Lemire. c'est pas du
tout et je pense qu'il l'a pas lu.
Pourtant, je lui ai offert mais je lui
ai dit à plusieurs reprises dans les
mystiques que il ferait bien de le lire.
Mais bon euh ceci étant euh si on en
revient au problème d'électricité, la
question qui se pose, c'est
effectivement comment on réinvestit le
champ de la production électrique parce
que on s'est laissé finalement un peu
intoxiqué par l'Europe. L'Europe
l'Europe avait à la tête de la
Commission européenne et puis dans la
Commission européenne, il y avait
surtout des gens qui étaient
antinucléaires. Donc ils nous ont fait
ils nous ont fait quand même arrêter pas
mal de choses sur le plan nucléaire et
qui étaient très énergie renouvelables
dites renouvelables qui sont en fait
intermittente qui sont renouvelables
mais aussi intermittentes. Et donc on
nous a poussé avec des objectifs
complètement démentiels des objectifs
comme si on avait une électricité qui
était très carbonée. Alors que grâce au
nucléaire grâce à l'hydroélectricité
aussi on a une énergie qui est très
décarbonée. En France on a notre
électricité quoi. l'électricité, je
parle pas de l'énergie en général, mais
l'électricité, elle est décarbonée à
plus de 90 %. Alors, me demandez pas ma
source, hein, c'est le ministère qui dit
ça, c'est tout le monde est d'accord sur
le fait de dire qu'aujourd'hui on a une
électricité très décarbonée. Donc le mix
électrique, il devrait pas être
idéologique. Il doit pas être de dire
tiens, on préfère les énergies, on
préfère le nucléaire, on préfère c ou
ça. On devrait écouter d'abord les
scientifiques et écouter aussi les
financiers parce que qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui devrait nous guider ? de
nous dire comment on produit à moindre
coût avec le moins de carbone et si
possible en développant des emplois en
France et une filière en France. Et
c'est ça qui devrait nous nous servir de
guide à nos choix. Et aujourd'hui, on n
pas du tout l'impression que c'est cela.
Alors, c'est en train de changer un peu
le gouvernement là dans on a réussi à
avoir un débat déjà à l'Assemblée, au
Sénat sur la programmation de l'énergie,
la programmation de la production
d'énergie. Donc on devait normalement le
texte devait sortir avec un décret,
c'estàd que c'est le gouvernement qui
décidait et il y avait aucun débat. Donc
on a réussi à obtenir ce débat et dans
ce débat on a senti qu'il y avait des
évolutions sensibles par rapport à ce
que disait André tout à l'heure dans la
copie que qui était préparée par
l'administration. Il faut savoir quand
même en France, même si l'administration
il y a il y a de très bons
fonctionnaires, mais c'est plutôt
l'administration qui décide que les
élus, hein. Je le dis pour on pense
qu'on est en démocratie mais honnêtement
sur les choix qui sont faits, c'est
beaucoup plus l'administration qui le
fait que les élus. Monsieur Merlin ?
Oui. Je vais vous poser une question
pour couper le politique parce que
j'adore couper les politiques. Allez-y,
allez-y. Euh
notre très
charismatique président de la
République, Emmanuel Macron, Oui. Il a
une moelle épinière concernant le
nucléaire ou il vogue avec le vent ? Bah
si vous voulez d'abord, c'est lui qui a
quand même décidé l'arrêt de Fonim.
C'était pas François Hollande ? Alors,
c'était envisagé par par François
Hollande, mais la fermeture a eu lieu en
2020 avec Édouard Philippe et c'était
Édouard Philippe qui était le premier
ministre euh Ellisabeth Born qui était
ministre en charge de l'énergie et de
l'écologie et c'est le président de la
République bien évidemment. Alors, il y
a eu une injonction, il faut quand même
le dire très clairement et qui datait
qui était qui était antérieure de la
chancelière allemande. Alors, ça tombe
bien parce que monsieur le sénateur
parlait de l'Union européenne. Vous vous
êtes polytechnicien ? Oui. On vous
raconte pas de carabistouille. Bah
écoutez, moi c'est le terme de la
soirée. Ouais. Non, c'est Non, parce que
c'est une blague entre nous.
Il y a pas un lobby antinucléaire
allemand qui est financé par les
Allemands et peut-être les Russes
derrière pour dézinguer notre avantage
compétitif et alors favoriser aussi
l'importation d'hydrocarbure russe. Oui.
Quand on a une moelle épinière, qu'on a
des épaules, qu'on respecte les impôts
de nos grands-parents qui ont fait le
programme thermonucléaire, on regarde
ces gens-là et on dit "Non mais ils
sortent d'où
Moi, si vous voulez ce qui s'est passé,
j'ai vécu ça parce que j'étais très
présent à
Bruxelles en début dans les années de
des années 2000. C'est moi d'ailleurs
qui ai créé l'association européenne des
gestionnaires de réseaux de transport
d'électricité à la demande de la
vice-présidente à l'époque de la
Commission européenne qui était l'Oyola
de Palacio qui avait le deux
caractéristiques. Elle était très
francophile par les
Français. Donc on a mis en place de ce
fait le marché européen de l'électricité
qui a été très critiqué. Bon, mais je
pense un petit peu à
tort et j'ai vécu ensuite le
basculement, c'est-à-dire que la perte
de leadership de la France repris par le
par les Allemands et les Allemands à
partir de 2006 ont repris le leadership
au niveau européen et c'est eux qui ont
imposé à toute l'Europe, à toute l'Union
européenne le fameux la fameuse
directive 3 x 20 en 2020. Alors,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire qu'en 2020, il fallait avoir 20 %
de baisse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre par rapport à
1990, 20 % d'énergie
renouvelable et uniquement d'énergie
renouvelable dans le mix euh énergétique
et 20 % d'économie d'énergie. Et dans
les 20 % euh de d'énergie renouvelable,
ben on avait oublié complètement le
nucléaire qui est français en
particulier, mais c'était
aussi qui ne comptait pas dans ces
objectifs. Donc déjà, on s'est fait
avoir à ce moment-là. Alors, je vais pas
dire qui, mais en tout cas, on aurait dû
s'opposer.
Faut dire qui ? Non, non, il faut dire
qui ? Oui. Ah bah c'est clairement
c'était l'époque où effectivement
c'était Nicolas Sarkozy qui en plus
présidait l'Union européenne pendant 6
mois quoi. Et donc cette cette décision
à mon avis alors 20 % c'était peu bien
évidemment surtout que ça incluait en
plus l'hydraulique. Donc on se disait ça
pas sauf que aujourd'hui c'est pas 20 %
c'est 42 % dans le mix énergétique et 42
% dans le mix énergétique européen ça
veut dire dans le mix électrique
européen 50 % d'énergie renouvelable
intermittente éolien et solaire.
Donc c'est ça qui est totalement
aberrant et c'est là où on voit
effectivement
l'influence de lobby
de disons qui défendent la
décroissance et qui fixent des objectifs
non seulement irréalistes mais
irrationnel on peut le dire des
raisonnables et qui plus partieux
puisque on oublie délibérément la part
qu'apporte le nucléaire dans le la
réduction des émissions de gaz àf de
serre. Donc c'est un combat qui va
falloir qu'on a commencé à mener
d'ailleurs mais qui va falloir mener au
niveau européen pour imposer
effectivement une neutralité
technologique entre le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables et en portugais
les énergies renouvelables
intermittentes. Monsieur le sénateur,
c'est en train de changer effectivement
sur le plan européen. On sent les
Allemands ont levé le verrou voilà et on
sent on sent qu'il y a des évolutions en
Allemagne aussi.
Il y a quand même beaucoup de pays. Il y
a il y a maintenant une alliance du
nucléaire qui s'est faite aussi au
niveau européen. Donc il y a il y a pas
mal de pays et ça c'est quand même un
progrès assez considérable. Donc on sent
bien que les les évolutions sont fortes
en la matière et tant mieux tant mieux
parce que il faut effectivement comme je
disais tout à l'heure sortir de
l'idéologie hein de se dire tiens on est
on est pour les renouvelables, on est
pour le nucléaire, on est non on est on
est pour effectivement être le plus
autonome possible sur la production
d'énergie et la seule production
d'énergie qu'on arrive à bien faire en
quantité c'est l'électricité. Donc c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on joue si on
veut effectivement être plus souverain
et plus compétitif dans l'avenir et que
la France ne s'effondre pas comme vous
vous pouvez le penser et que certains
peuvent le penser. Donc on a intérêt à
réinvestir complètement ce domaineel qui
était un domaine d'excellence pour la
France et un domaine dans lequel on
pouvait exporter et on exportait notre
technique et notre savoir-faire.
Aujourd'hui, on l'a perdu en grande
partie. Alors, il reste encore un
certain nombre de de personnes qui sont
encore compétentes, mais il faut pas il
faut pas traîner. Et effectivement, on a
vu avec Flamville là, on a on a
construit un un prototype à Flamville,
un EPR, on veut en construire pas mal.
Il faut réussir à réindustrialiser, à
faire des séries de façon à faire
baisser les coûts et à ce que ça soit
compétitif. On en profite pour embrasser
EDF et tous leurs salariés qui font un
boulot extraordinaire, surtout pendant
le Covid, on tout le monde façon. On
embrasse tout le monde. Ah non mais EDF
il mérite. Il mérite parce que vous vous
n'imaginez pas le professionnalisme de
ces gens. Et pendant votre commission,
ça parle de nucléaire. Est-ce que vous
avez fait une petite prospective un peu
de renseignement sur les quantités
d'uranium disponibles ? Parce que
s'amuser à faire des réacteurs à gogo.
S'il y a plus de combustible dans cazz
rapport 20 ans. Oui. Croy au moins la
synthèse, on travaille sur ces questions
depuis plus de 10 ans et on vous a pas
on vous a pas fait déplacer pour pousser
un cadit. Donc en terme de prospective
uranium, on entend un suisse allemand
qui connaît bien son rayon qui dit
"C'est compliqué, on voit le Kazakhstan
qui a des problèmes pour délivrer. On
dit que ça ça va." On dit "Ah bah on a
entre 2 et 10 ans de réserve en France."
Alors entre 2 et 10 hein. On voit que
l'Inde, la Chine, les États-Unis et puis
un peu tout le monde se veut se mettre
au nucléaire. Quand vous prenez un
réacteur d'un GW, il consomme deux fois
plus quand on l'allume tout de suite.
C'estàd qu'il faut à la fois les crayon
de combustible, mais il faut le double
en fin de compte quand on en crée un.
Donc là, il y a combien de réacteurs en
France ? 56 56 56 réacteurs moins F
Ah oui, il y a F maintenant il y en a
57. On a perdu deux réacteurs lors de la
fermeture de Fenheim et on en a gagné un
avec le démarrage de Flamville. Donc la
prospective sur les quantités d'uranium
disponibles à quel prix parce que notre
notre Suisse allemand extraordinaire
d'ailleurs. Il nous dit bon bah les
mines sont par là, le Canada les mines
sont par là, les États-Unis vont avoir
parler sur l'autre bout. Voilà, ils vont
ils vont délivrer les Chinois en
priorité.
Alors alors en tout cas c'est un sujet
sur lequel on a on a effectivement
travaillé parce qu'on en parle assez
peu. C'est bien qu'on en parle ce soir
parce que c'est vrai qu'on on se dit on
va relancer 14 PR2 qu'il faut il faut
repartir. Mais effectivement est-ce
qu'on aura du combustible ? C'est une
bonne question parce que quand on a on
fait des centrales aujourd'hui, c'est
pour 60 ans voir peut-être 100 ans et
nous quoi tous les pays à la COP 28 ont
annoncé globalement qu'il y aurait un
triplement du nucléaire dans le monde
d'ici 2050. Donc on est parti sur cette
hypothèse là. Est-ce qu'elle sera tenue
ou est-ce qu'elle sera pas tenue ? J'en
sais rien mais en tout cas il fallait
bien partir d'une hypothèse et avec ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui des réserves
qui existent existantes qui sont
effectivement parfois dans des pays
quand même sur lesquels on peut avoir
des doutes euh géostratégiques et autres
l'Australie l'Australie extraordinaire
l'Australie et le Canada mais si s'il
reste plus que c'est pas sûr que ça soit
la France qui soit servie en première
donc quand on on se dit les choses
Nigère bah non Nigère
on sait pas trop Kazakhstan sa pas trop
tout ça. Bon, donc ce qu'il faut
regarder, nous on a regardé sans sans
problème géopolitique et sans sans
conflit majeur en se disant tout est
accessible mais on a connaissance. Nous,
on arrive plutôt à des pénuries dans les
années 2070
2080. Voilà, certains disent 2100. OK.
Bon, même si on dit 2100, ça nous paraît
très lointain. On est en 2025, on a 75
ans devant nous. Mais si on construit
aujourd'hui des EPR2, ils vont sortir le
premier va sortir éventuellement en
2038. S'il sort au mieux, ça sera comme
en 2038. Et ça s'étalera jusqu'en 2050
pour des centrales qui ont 60 ou 80 ans
de durée de vie. Donc il est possible
qu'en cours de vie, ils aient plus de
combustible. En tout cas que qu'on soit
à cours de combustible. C'est pour ça
que nous on a dit attention attention
n'allons pas trop au loin sur la
construction de BR2. Essayons de
réfléchir à la 4e génération. les
réacteurs à neutron rapide. On a du
plutonium en quantité, on a on a là des
centaines d'années de combustible et on
était très en avance sur le sujet donc
avec Super Phenix, avec Astrid, on a
arrêté tout ça mais il faut reprendre
très rapidement ce sujet-là. Il faut pas
traîner parce que avant que ça soit au
point, il va falloir au moins 20 à 30
ans. Donc voilà. Donc pardon non c'est
moi. Non non mais on on on a avant de
pouvoir commencer à industrialiser le
les réacteurs à ne trom rapide. Alors
avant de redonner la parole à monsieur
Merlin quelle question je lui pose Hervé
non non non on se concentre 2 secondes.
Hervé
vous avez établi un scénario qui
prolonge les courbes où tout est calme.
Comment ça se fait que vous sénateur
vous ayez pas eu la présence d'esprit de
faire le scénario art ? C'est quand tout
le monde il est tout le monde il est
gentil. Le scénario B, on s'énerve un
peu. Et le scénario C, le plus probable,
on s'énerve beaucoup. On s'énerve avec
une dislocation géopolitique, des
tension à gauche, des tensions à droite.
Euh, ça devient compliqué pour tout le
monde parce que parce que alors moi je
je m'appelle Vincent hein. Pardon ?
Vincent, c'est pas très grave. Hervé,
Vincentr
André, c'est Vincent. Mais simplement
simplement nous on a disposé de 6 mois
pour faire notre commission d'enquête.
Donc, on n pas plus de 6 mois. C'estàd
que si on sort pas notre rapport avant
les les 6 mois, il est perdu. Et
d'ailleurs, il est sorti en pleine
dissolution juste après la dissolution
qu'on avait pas vu venir. Excusez-moi,
j'ai pas tout prévu mais on avait pas
prévu la dissolution. Ça a surpris tout
le monde et les Jeux Olympiques, ils
étaient prévus mais donc on était entre
la dissolution et les Jeux Olympiques.
C'est vrai que notre rapport il sortait
pas au bon moment mais on pouvait pas
non plus et on n pas des moyens infinis
pour notre commission d'enquête. donc
faire beaucoup de scénarios différents
mais déjà le scénario au fil de l'eau
sans trop de problème truc nous semblait
déjà assez alarmant comme cela. Donc
c'est vrai que si on le complique avec
des problèmes géopolitiques et et
d'autres c'est sûr qu'il va être encore
plus alarmant. C'estàd qu'on pourrait se
dire en 2050 on a plus d'uranium
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Euh alors bon on
a on aura quand même des EPR2 mais s'il
y a plus d'uranium je peux demander à
André si s'il a une solution miracle.
Mais je suis pas sûr qu'il a une
solution miracle. Donc nous voilà, on on
n pas eu le temps de creuser tout à fond
mais ce sujet-là, on voulait quand même
au moins avoir un
scénario. Moi, mon point de vue, c'est
que il y a il y a encore beaucoup
d'uranium sur et même en France, on a on
a fermé des mines. Dans mon pays qui est
le limite de la Corè et du Crantal, il y
a une mine d'uranium. Elle a été fermée
parce que elle était pas assez rentable
et on a préféré effectivement utiliser
de l'uranium venant par exemple du
Nigère qui était moins moins coûteux.
Mais si nécessaire, on pourra réouvrir
cette cette mine. Par contre, je je
rejoins le point de vue de de Vincent.
Je pense effectivement il faut préparer
l'avenir et effectivement dès maintenant
préparer la 4e génération, c'estàd des
des réacteurs à neutron rapide qui ont
l'avantage par rapport au réacteur
actuel de pouvoir utiliser la totalité
de l'uranium venant de la mine et qui
plus on peut recycler des ce qu'on
appelle des déchets comme le plutonium
qui peuvent recycler dans ces réacteurs
à neutron rapide.
On avait fait une une erreur manifeste
qui a été soulignée d'ailleurs lors de
la la commission d'enquête sur la perte
de souveraineté énergétique de la
France. Euh c'est la commission
d'enquête de l'Assemblée nationale. On a
fermé Super
Phenniix euh en 2000.
Je crois que c'est autour des 2000 et
pour des raisons idéologiques. Il y
avait aucune raison de on avait une
avance considérable sur le plan
technique hein. Et on a fermé on a fermé
Super Phéniix. Bon et qui plus on avait
relancé avec le projet Astrid l'idée de
de repartir sur un nouveau prototype de
réacteur à neutron rapide. Bah, il y a
eu effectivement un
arrêt et maintenant il y a un
redémarrage. La dernière comité de
production nucléaire, ce qui non mais
c'est important, excusez-moi là de juste
interrompre, mais c'est important de
dire qu'en matière énergétique, faut pas
vous laisser faire monsieur. Il faut pas
il faut pas de stop and go. Vous
connaissez vous connaissez les
politiques hein, vous leur donzit on
leur donne ça et non mais juste juste le
stop and go en matière énergétique c'est
catastrophique parce que c'est des
investissements de long terme dans
lesquels l'état et la puissance publique
est obligé de s'investir parce que sinon
personne n'y va et à partir de là il
faut pas se dire tiens on a commencé
quelque chose on l'arrête dans 5 ans au
bout de 5 ans et on reprend autre chose
et après il faut vraiment avoir une
ligne et c'est pour ça qu'il faut sortir
il faut sortir de l'idéologie moi je je
ce que je souhaite vraiment c'est que
sur ce sujet-là, on sort de l'idéologie
pour être vraiment sur les choix
techniques, scientifiques et financiers
aussi. Sébastien, notre communauté nous
dit Orano vient de décrocher un contrat
en Mongolie pour l'exploitation d'une
mine d'uranium. Oui. Oui. Monsieur
Merlin, bah écoutez, c'est une bonne
nouvelle. Non, mais avant que monsieur
le sénateur vous coupe la parole, vous
étiez en train Non, c'est pas grave,
c'est pas grave.
Non non, mais je pense qu'il faut
effectivement préparer le futur et la
décision qui a été prise en comité de
production de de nucléaire par le chef
de l'État est une très bonne décision.
Ce qu'on peut regretter, c'est que une
période où on a arrêté effectivement le
projet Astruide. Il y avait aucune
raison de l'arrêter. Je sais pas
pourquoi on l'a arrêté. Il y avait pas
de Il fallait une continuité. C'est ce
que ce qu'a dit effectivement Vincent.
Donc euh on peut se féliciter et
l'avenir effectivement c'est sans doute
d'avoir des réacteurs euh de 4e
génération. Et là je pense que euh il
faut viser le la 2e partie du 21e siècle
hein, c'est-à-dire euh Vincent disait
2070. Oui, c'est 2000 2060 2070. On
verra pas, on sera tous mangés par les
verrs. Oui. Oui. Euh juste un détail,
l'Europe, ses capacités de production
par rapport à la Chine, ça vous fait pas
trop peur ? Qui est-ce qui veut
récupérer pas chose ? Je pense je pense
que l'Europe, enfin je dirais la
Commission européenne se fourvoie
actuellement complètement complètement.
Et ce qu'il faut au niveau européen, moi
c'est c'est ce que je dis et en tant
qu'européen, je parle en tant
qu'européen. J'ai été conseiller spécial
de la Commission européenne pour
l'énergie à une époque hein. Donc je je
le dis, il faut faire un plan
mesmè à l'échelle européenne et je pense
qu'on va y arriver. Je sais pas dans
quel délai mais je même le Danemark
actuellement le Danemark envisage de
construire des réacteurs nucléaire parce
qu'on voit bien l'impasse si vous voulez
et surtout que comme je l'ai dit
précédemment les énergies renouvelables
intermittentes accroissent de manière
très importante les risques de blackout
on le voit sur ce qui est
passé en sur la péninsule ibérique.
L'objectif de la PPE, tenez-vous bien,
c'est de multiplier par 3 la part des
renouvelables intermittents d'ici 2035
et par 6 d'ici 2050. C'est complètement
déraisonnable. C'est déraisonnable sur
le plan économique, sur le plan du prix
de l'électricité. C'est ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure, mais ça fait courir des
risques majeurs de blackout au niveau
européen. Vincent non mais moi je sur un
plan européen euh c'est indispensable et
effectivement on en prend la direction
mais je pense que c'est c'est c'est un
des domaines sur lesquels on peut se
distinguer complètement. On a on a de la
compétence, on a on a des quand même
encore des ingénieurs mais on peut en
redévelopper pas mal parce que il faut
quand même reconstituer aussi
toute toute notre capacité de de
réflexion et faut combien de temps il
faut combien de temps pour faire un
ingénieur monsieur Merlin ? Oh, écoutez,
euh mon avis, il y a il y a toutes les
études normales, ça dure trop plus la
préparation, ça fait 5 ans, plus après
la formation particulière, il faut bien
effectivement 7 8 ans quoi. Et pour
construire un réacteur, il faut combien
de temps ? Alors, les réacteurs euh
c'est là aussi il y a un il y a un point
qui mérite quand on est à l'époque du
plan Mesmer hein et de vous citizier
Bernard Esambert, on avait réalisé on on
construisait les réacteurs en 5
ans et on a
réussi à mettre en service une même
année jusqu'à h réacteurs. Vous rendez
compte ? h réacteurs et on les
construisait en 5 ans. Aujourd'hui, ce
qui paraît envisagé actuellement, c'est
de l'ordre de 10 ans dans la première
série sur les les les six EPR2, mais on
peut espérer que effectivement s'il y a
s'il y a une suite à ces six, c'est les
h
suivants, le délai va se raccourcir.
Alors, sera-t-il de 7 8 ans ? Plus c'est
long, plus le prix le prix de revient du
du kilowatt nucléaire est élevé. Si vous
voulez, actuellement on est, il faut le
dire très clairement, on est à un prix
du kilowatt de l'ordre de 10000 € alors
que les les les kilw non 10000 € le kilw
d'investissement un investissement
j'attends je parle pas de d'énergie 1 kW
10000 €
en en
Chine ils ils ont copié hein au début
ils avaient pris exactement ce que le
même modèle que celui qu'on avait
réalisé du temps du plan BMER c'était
une copie conforme du réacteur de
Graveline. Aujourd'hui, ils ont leur
propre filière et tenez-vous bien, ils
construisent ces réacteurs en 5 ans
comme on le faisait auparavant. Et
résultat, le prix est divisé par 4. Il
est actuellement de 2500 € par kilw.
Vincent ? Non mais complètement mais
quoi ? Moi je je partage ce que je viens
de dire André, ça me paraît évident. Ce
qui est un peu bizarre quand on regarde,
c'est que on arrive à faire des choses
dans les années 80 effectivement avec
rapidité, efficacité et autres et on se
dit on est 40 50 ans plus tard et on n'y
arrive plus. Et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? Il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont complexifiées. C'estàd qu'il y a
une réglementation qui est maintenant
beaucoup plus drastique parce que bah il
y a eu des accidents aussi. Il y a eu
Fukushima, il y a eu des choses qui ont
fait que on a on a complexifié, on a
durci les règles de sécurité. Je dis pas
qu'il
faut les les réduire mais il faut quand
même regarder tout ce qu'on peut
simplifier pour aller un petit peu plus
vite sans perdre sur la sécurité. Donc
c'est c'est pas si facile que cela, mais
on doit pouvoir y arriver de façon à
réindustrialiser ce secteur et avoir
vraiment une capacité de production
rapide parce que c'est indispensable
pour l'avenir. Alors moi j'écoute madame
Panier
Runachier qui nous dit "On va engager
100000 personnes dans le
nucléaire. C'est c'est quoi ? C'est
c'est il y a qu'à faucon. C'est beaucoup
combien on forme on ferme ? 10000
ingénieurs par an ?" Non. Euh oui, de
l'ord de cette j'aurais tendance à dire
10000 ingénieurs 100000. Ça veut dire ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que pendant
10 ans on a que des ingénieurs dans le
nucléaire. Non non, il y a des
soudeurs, il y a des il y a les soudeurs
en particulier très important 2030 ça
fait combien par jour ?
Écoutez, j'aime bien les chiffres mais
là ça va un peu vite là. Et donc non ben
je pas on entend beaucoup les
politiciens s'agit. On les entend
essayer de combler leur retard
intellectuel sur les questions
énergétiques. Arrêter de se payer sur la
bête que nos prédécesseurs ont fait
après le le choc
pétrolier. Quand on a un polytechnicien
qui analyse le politique et les caps
énergétiques d'une nation comme la
France, vous vous arrachez les cheveux
monsieur Merlin ou pas du tout ? Bon ben
si vous voulez euh il me reste encore
quelques années à vivre et je 30 ans au
minimum. J'en sais rien. J'en sais rien.
Mais en tout cas je suis à la retraite
et mon combat c'est effectivement aussi
bien au niveau français qu'au niveau
européen de faire les bons choix
énergétiques. C'est pour ça que j'ai été
auditionné par l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat que j'ai participé récemment à
une conférence de presse au Sénat où on
a dit les choses clairement. Mais vous
avez dit quoi ? Oouille. J'ai en
particulier dit que les conséquences sur
le prix de l'électricité. Alors, on m'a
traité sur les réseaux sociaux de
malhonnête égal qui qui je vais pas
citer les noms mais des gens qui
défendent en particulier les éoliennes
et les panneaux solaires parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'argent dans cette affaire
beaucoup. Et on sait pas toujours d'où
il vient. Alors pas trop de suputation
ici c'est soit on sait soit on sait pas.
Oui mais si vous voulez oui je c'est
vrai que je moi j'ai pas soit on dit
soit on dit pas. Bah, écoutez, ce que je
sais, c'est que ça coûte très cher et
que très souvent il s'agit de euh de
fondations qui qui sont situées à
l'étranger, soit en Suisse, soit en au
Luxembourg. Et on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
de à partir de là d'où vient d'où vient
cet argent. Est-ce que quand vous avez
vous avez témoigné ça lors de la
conférence de presse auprès de nos
politiciens, ils ont quelle a été leur
réaction politique ? politicien c'est
c'est un peu négatif c'est
vrai le Sénat était très très à
l'écoute. Je je crois on je crois pas le
ils ont justifié leur salaire ou pas ?
J'en sais rien. En tout cas ils ont été
à mon avis c'est eux qui qui ont
organisé d'ailleurs la conférence de
presse. C'est moi j'y a j'y ai
participé. Donc euh mais si vous voulez
l'enjeu est tel parce que j'ai parlé
surtout de l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité pour les particuliers mais
il y a aussi l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité pour les industriels. qui
alors dans un pays où on parle de
réindustrialisation et je pense
qu'effectivement il faut viser si on va
si on suit cette programmation plurielle
de l'énergie et bien la conséquence
c'est la mon estimation elle vaut ce
qu'elle vaut c'est une augmentation du
prix de l'électricité pour les
industriels de l'ordre de 30 % alors
qu'actuellement le prix de
l'électricité en France qui est le par
bien le plus bas d'Europe on peut le
dire hein grâce au nucléaire enfin bon
un peu moins
Un peu moins maintenant, c'est vrai un
peu moins. Ça l'était ça l'était ça un
petit peu moins. C'est vrai, c'est vrai.
Mais c'est ça reste la meilleure preuve,
c'est que EDF exporte a exporté 100 TW
100 milliards de kWh en 2024. Et
pourquoi il f a exporté dans les pays
voisins cette quantité d'électricité ?
Parce que le prix euh en France était
inférieur au prix de dans les pays
voisins. Donc il faut le dire, grâce au
nucléaires, on a un prix mais il est
quand même beaucoup plus élevé. C'est ce
qu'a dit le président de de Michelin
lorsqu'il a été auditionné au Sénat, je
crois. Dur hein. C'est effectivement euh
aux États-Unis c'est 60 € du MWh. Pour
les industriels en France c'est 106 €.
C'est les chiffres donnés par le
président de Michel. Et bien je prétends
que si effectivement on suit la PPE,
c'est 30 % de plus, c'estàd qu'on sera à
136. Donc les industriels qui ont besoin
d'énergie, bah ils auront tendance à
aller ailleurs. Voilà. Monsieur de
monsieur le sénateur, quand on entend
notre premier ministre, comment il
s'appelle déjà ? François Berou François
Ber nous annoncer que nos futurs
investissements, ils tapent sur 100 100
€ le MW. C'est ça. Quand on voit l'unia
qui fait des
pneus taper durement en disant la
réindustrialisation, ça va être
compliqué, il faut arrêter de de faire
du bruit avec votre bouche. Il a pas dit
ça mais entre les lignes, ça voulait
dire ça. Oui. Le politique le politique
pardon, quand il prend ça dans la tête,
il se dit "Bon, alors mon mandat, il se
finit dans 3 ans, on va refiler la pâte
à chose. Ou il est il agit en homme
d'état Ça dépend des politiques. Ça
dépend des politiques. Ça dépend des
journalistes, ça dépend des
scientifiques, ça dépend de beaucoup de
choses. Alors ça dép Alors ça fait quoi
? Non mais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Bien sûr qu'il faut traiter
le le sujet. Il faut traiter le sujet
parce que ce que dit André est vrai. On
a l'électricité était un pas très cher
en France. elle a augmenté quand même
sensiblement le fait des aides qu'on a
apporté justement aux énergies d'ites
renouvelable et lien au photovoltaïques.
On a quand même aidé de façon
considérable et certains souhaitent
qu'on continue à aider de façon
considérable. C'est là où il faut
s'arrêter à un moment donné. Il faut il
faut pouvoir dire stop. Bon ok on l'a
fait. On a essayé de développer une
filière. On a essayé de favoriser euh si
ça ça aujourd'hui parce que je reviens
simplement sur les coûts hein, ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure, quand on compare
des coûts, il faut comparer les coûts
complets, c'estàdire qu'avec les réseaux
parce que euh vous savez bon, il y a il
y a le prix de production de
l'électricité, il y a le prix de du
transport de des réseaux et puis il y a
la fiscalité. Quand on va revenir sur le
prix, il y a il y a ces trois
composantes là. Là, on a pas mal parlé
de la production, mais il y a aussi le
le transport. Et c'est vrai que les les
éoliennes comme le photovoltaïque, en
fait, ils sont non seulement
intermittents, mais aussi assez diffus.
Ce qui fait que sur les réseaux, ça a un
coût négligeable. Et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui euh Nedis euh et RTE
prévoit à peu près 200 milliards
d'investissements dans les 15 prochaines
années, hein. Ça c'est la source
officielle. Tout à fait. Et làdedans, il
y en a quand même une bonne part qui
concerne les énergies dites
renouvelables. Donc cet argent là, il va
pas sortir comme ça par magie de nulle
part. Donc il faut il faut il faut
arrêter de se tromper parce qu'en fait
on s'est quand même trompé en grande
partie et il faut maintenant faire des
choix qui soient rationnels. Et les
choix rationnels, il faut que bien sûr
les politiques poussent dans ce sens-là
mais il faut que tout le monde y compris
les citoyens regarde parce que je sais
que vous vous aimez bien aussi qu'on
donne des conseils un peu aux citoyens.
Il faut que les citoyens, ils
s'intéressent à ces questions-là et qui
nous euh et qui sollicitent le
gouvernement et tous les décideurs pour
que on aille dans des euh direction et
des choix qui soient bien raisonnés. Et
je je dirais, je prends simplement un
exemple pour appuyer ce que vient de
dire
Vincent. Vous construisez un parc éolien
offshore de 1000 MW, ce qui est le
standard à peu près envisagé. Il faut le
relier au grands réseaux de transport
d'électricité, aux autoroutes
électriques dont je parlais tout à
l'heure, c'est le réseau à 400000 V.
Vous ne pouvez le faire qu'avec des
liaisons sous-marines et
souterraines. On est obligé à ce
moment-là de transformer le courant
alternatif qui est produit au niveau des
parcs éoliens en courant continu.
Transporter l'électricité en courant
continu jusqu'au point de raccordement
au grand réseau et à nouveau le le
retransformer en courant alternatif.
Pour 1000 MW, c'est 1 milliard d'euros
d'investissement.
On envisage, on c'est pas payé par le le
celui qui construit le le parc le le
parc éolien, c'est payé par l'ensemble
des consommateurs. Donc si vous si dans
la PPE, on prévoit 20 GW d'éoliens marin
d'ici 2035, ben ça fait 20 milliards.
D'ici 2050, ça a été annoncé par
Emmanuel Macron lors de son discours à
Bfort, c'est 45 GW, c'est 45 milliards.
Et qu'est-ce et ça se retrouve à ce
moment-là dans le ce qu'on appelle le
turbe, c'est en quelque sorte le coût
d'acheminement, le prix d'achem, c'est
un pH quoi que vous faites payer. Et là
tout le monde le paye, non seulement les
consommateurs domestiques mais également
les industriels. Et c'est pour ça que je
dis ça va avoir une augmentation de 30
%. Il faut que
l'administration qui propose ces ce ce
programme plurannuel de l'énergie se
projette à 2035 voir à 2050 et disent
voilà quel sera le niveau du péage à
cette époque-là. C'est à eux de le dire.
Moi je je fais une estimation qui vaut
ce qu'elle vaut. elle est à la louche
mais il doit et et la commission de
régulation de l'énergie qui a tous les
éléments mêmes peut effectivement
alimenter l'administration qui est en
charge de ces affairesl pour dire voilà
ce que ça va coûter au consommateur
aussi bien au consommateurs domestique
qu'au consommateurs industriel. Monsieur
Merlin, combien ça coûte un réacteur
d'un gw à faire en France ? E bien si
vous voulez un réacteur de de d' 1 GW,
je dirais que c'est euh je je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure euh je c'est 10000 €
du kW, donc ça fait euh 10 milliards. Un
réacteur 10 milliards, mais ça ça dure
80 ans et un parc éolien ça dure combien
de temps ? Alors c'est 20
ans. Donc après on en fait quoi ? Pardon
? Après on en fait quoi ? Ben il faut le
renouveler. Il faut il faut
reconstruire. On recycle on le recycle
pas. Alors, on recycle peut-être quelque
chose mais je vois Vincent faire du
bruit. Non, non, mais je pense qu'on
recycle pas grand-chose. On recycle pas
grand-chose et je pense que les coûts
d'ailleurs de de démantellement ne sont
pas vraiment intégrés à quoi que ce
soit. Donc, on va avoir devant nous des
des gros problèmes parce qu'à un moment
donné, on va demander à des à des
propriétaires de champ éolien ou autres
de démanteler leurs installations et il
y aura plus d'argent. Il ils diront "Ah
ben non, nous on n pas d'argent. Voyez,
avec les propriétaires, voyez et je
pense que ça c'est un sujet qui est pas
du tout abordé mais qui est un sujet à
mon avis à anticipé dès maintenant. Vous
touchez de l'argent du lobby nucléaire
ou pas du tout ? Moi je touche rien du
tout. Même pas un petit voyage, zéro
voyage. Je suis pas allé à Ternobyl, on
m'a pas on m'a pas invité là-bas. Et
non, honnêtement, bon moi je je j'essaie
d'être objectif le plus objectif
possible. J'essaie de voir ce qui est
l'intérêt de la France, ce qui est
l'intérêt des Français. C'est ça qui est
qui nous intéresse et puis on est tous
là pour travailler pour l'intérêt
général puisque c'est ça qu'on
recherche. Donc l'intérêt général, si on
nous démontre que c'est de développer
des parcs éoliens en mer, ben on dira
OK. Mais pour l'instant, c'est loin
d'être démontré. C'est loin d'être
démontré euh que ça soit intéressant
financièrement. Ça va se retrouver quand
même dans la facture comme on l'a dit,
hein. Moi, je reviens un peu sur la
facture d'électricité parce que la
facture d'électricité, il y a il y a il
y a la production, le transport et la
fiscalité. Et nous notre commission
d'acquête, on a pas mal parlé de la
fiscalité parce que la fiscalité
finalement c'est ce qu'on peut ce ce sur
quoi on peut agir assez facilement même
si même si dans le transport si on prend
des bonnes décisions, on on limitera les
les impacts. Mais aujourd'hui, on a une
électricité qui est nettement plus taxée
que toutes les énergies fossiles et qui
est nettement plus taxé que le gaz, qui
est nettement plus taxé que que le
pétrole, que le fiou domestique et dans
des proportions importantes. C'estàd que
c'est quatre fois plus, c'est h fois
plus dans un autre cas. Donc ça c'est
euh il faut et ça c'est le l'association
des des fournisseurs d'électricité qui
c'est la source. C'est ça puisque vous
me demander les sources, c'est pas c'est
pas Vincent de la c'est c'est une
source. Et donc il faut arriver alors
qu'on a une énergie décarbonée qu'on
veut produire en France, qu'on peut
produire en France, il y en a pas
beaucoup, on devrait inverser
complètement ce rapport. C'est qu'on
devrait beaucoup plus fiscaliser le
parce que si on avait une situation
financière excellente, je vous dirais
OK, on baisse et il y a pas de souci, on
arrive à compenser ça. Mais ne soyez pas
si populiste, notre situation financière
est parfaite. Est parfaite. Bon, je suis
content de trouver quelqu'un qui la
trouve parfaite et j'avais du mal mais
je serais je serais content d'en
débattre avec vous si vous voulez qu'on
fasse une autre émission uniquement sur
la fiscalité et sur les sur ce qu'il
faut faire sur la situation financière.
Moi, je suis prêt à le faire et j'ai pas
de sujet tabou et j'ai pas de j'ai pas
peur. J'ai j'ai pas de crainte parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de politiques qui ont
des craintes. À chaque fois qu'on aborde
un sujet, ils disent "Attention, il y a
des gens qui vont pas être contents."
Bon, mais ceci étant dit, sur la
fiscalité, moi je pense que il faut
baisser la fiscalité sur l'électricité.
Donc on a fait des propositions parce
que il y a trois il y a trois taxas sur
l'électricité. Il y a il y a la TVA, il
y a l'assise sur électricité qu'on a
augmenté récemment hein, on l'a pas
baissé, on l'a augmenté. C'est comme
comme le prix d'électricité a baissé,
vous vous connaissez un peu le le
mécanisme du prix d'électricité avec les
les tarifs réglementés ? Comment il le
principe des taxes ? C'estàd qu'ils
augmentent les taxes pour cacher leurs
conneries. Non non non non, je vous dis
rapidement, il s'est passé il y a eu un
choc sur les prix d'énergie donc en 2022
2023 ça a augmenté considérablement. Qui
c'est qui aurait pu prédire ? et
personne s'en fout ou sans peut-être
Bruno mais mais les prix les prix ont
augmenté quand même les prix ont
augmenté considérablement et du coup les
tarifs réglementés ils sont basés sur
les deux années précédentes. Donc en
2024 il s'était passé sur 2022 2023 où
les prix étaient très élevés. En 2024
les prix ont baissé. Il continuent
d'ailleurs à baisser en 2025. Donc en
2024, on aurait dû avoir une baisse du
prix d'électricité de 25 % à peu près.
C'est pas ce que vous avez constaté sur
vos factures. Sur sur les factures, on a
on a constaté en moyenne parce que ça
dépend du fournisseur, ça dépend de
plein de trucs, 15 peut-être un peu
moins de 15. Et la différence, elle est
passée dans les taxes. C'estd que le
gouvernement augmenté les taxes qui lui
a permis de dire "Ah ben vous voyez, on
baisse le prix de l'électricité et en
même temps encaisser des taxes de
l'autre côté." Il fallait bien combler
le trou de monsieur 1000 milliards quand
même. Non mais attendez, il y a plein de
trous à combler. Donc moi je pense pas
que ça soit sur l'électricité qu'il
faille combler les trous. Donc je vous
l'ai dit, je pense que c'est plutôt les
énergies fossiles sur lesquelles il faut
puisque c'est
elles qu'on qu'on souhaite diminuer voir
diminuer. C'est plutôt là-dessus qu'il
faut. Et alors que sur l'électricité, il
faut plutôt moi, je suis pour que on
puisse baisser la TVA, qu'on puisse
baisser l'assise sur électricité. Et la
dernière chose qui qui touche aux
électricité, c'est c'est un petit truc,
ça s'appelle la contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement. Donc si vous la
comprenez bien, ça veut dire que vous
pensez que c'est du transport de
l'électricité, contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement. En fait non, en fait
c'est pour payer les
retraites. Le système le régime des
retraites, il est payé en partie.
Monsieur Merlin, c'est votre faute. Il
va dire dans le c'est pas du tout la
faute de monsieur Merlin. Monsieur
Merlin a bien travaillé, il mérite sa
retraite. Il y a aucun souci. Non mais
c'est c'est c'est pas clair. Quand vous
voulez quand vous voulez parler des
choses avec les gens, il faut quand même
que ça soit clair. Vous leur dites on
vous facture une contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement. En fait non, c'est une
contribution pour la retraite. Appant
contribution pour la retraite. Moi je
suis pour qu'on la supprime et qu'on la
compense avec une subvention de l'État.
que ça soit bien clair, on subventionne
le régime parce que il a besoin d'être
subventionné pour pouvoir verser les
portions de retraite. Donc nous, on a
proposé à la commission d'enquête, on n
pas proposé une baisse générale parce
que on s'est dit baisse générale, ça va
être ça va faire trop d'argent. et Bruno
Lemire qui nous dit qu'il est à l'euro
prêt à l'époque, il nous disait qu'il
était à l'euro prêt avec ou sur le col
roulé, j'en sais rien. Mais euh et du
coup, il était cette baisse, nous on l'a
ciblé sur les
consommations de base. Ce qu'on appelait
la consommation de base, ça veut dire
les petites consommations. ça c'est ve
dire petite consommation, vous vous avez
aussi une petite consommation parce que
tout le monde paye en fait une partie de
consommation et au-delà de cette
consommation de base, on restait sur le
système actuel pour ne pas pénaliser
trop les finances de l'État, mais on
pourrait aller plus loin. Nous, on l'a
fait pour limiter un peu l'impact sur
les finances et on s'est dit c'est juste
finalement tout le monde est touché mais
celui qui consomme énormément, il va
être touché à la marge. Celui qui
consomme assez peu, celui qui a pas
beaucoup de moyens et qui consomme assez
peu, lui il va être touché à plein et
d'habitude. Mais non, mais justement là
dans le bon sens quand quand je dis à
plein c'est dans le bon sens, je suis
désolé de l'expression mais en réalité
comme on baisse la fiscalité lui il va
voir la baisse de son prix d'électricité
sur la totalité de sa consommation. Donc
voilà, je je pense que c'est une
direction qu'on doit prendre même si
elle est parfois difficile à faire
passer notamment pour imposer un peu
plus les énergies fossiles mais c'est
indispensable que monsieur Merlin qui a
préparé son famass. Écoutez moi moi
c'est un point effectivement il faut
savoir que actuellement l'accise ce
qu'on appelle l'accise elle comprend
effectivement plusieurs taxes mais il y
a une part c'est ce qu'a dit d'ailleurs
Bruno Lemire à une
époque je le cite avec son col rô
peut-être au total on peut dire que
c'est c'est de l'ordre de 40 € hors TVA
il y a là-dessus il y a il y a la TVA
sur ces 40 € il y a 21 T1 € qui est lié
aux subventions aux énergies
renouvelables
il faut le dire et on n pas pu revenir à
la subvention qu'il y avait avant la
crise énergétique qui était de 31. Ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que la
différence entre 31 et 21, c'est pris en
charge dans le budget de l'État. Donc ça
creuse la dette. Mais ce qui est
beaucoup plus grave, c'est que si on
prend si on si on applique le programme
tel qu'il est prévu par la PPE, le
programme pluriannuel de l'énergie, moi
je je prétends que cette taxe va être
multipliée par 3 et je suis prêt à à le
démontrer par trois. C'est-à-dire que
euh si vous voulez, il faut les
subventions, il faut savoir qui les paye
hein. C'est soit l'État, soit soit le
consommateur. Et comme on veut pas faire
payer l'État, c'est nous et c'est nous
l'État, c'est moi pas le faire payer, on
fait payer aux entreprises. C'est que
c'est soit alors les entreprises, on les
épargne d'une certaine manière, surtout
les industriels et on ne fait payer que
les l'augmentation du péage, ce dont je
parlais tout à l'heure. Mais les
subventions directes sont payées par les
consommateurs domestiques et puis
peut-être par les toutes petites
moyennes et et PME PMI. Et c'est ça qui
ne va pas. On ne peut pas l'accepter et
c'est à l'administration de dire
effectivement de faire ce calcul et de
le donner à
la à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat.
On peut se projeter à 10 ans et faire ce
calcul et ça on ne veut pas le faire. On
on met le le la merde sous le tapis.
Voilà. Exactement. Je dirais pas la
merde mais poussière. La poussière la
poussière sous le tapis. Je je j'ouvre
une parenthèse. On va faire une petite
digression vu qu'on commence à se
détendre.
Monsieur le sénateur dit bon qui aurait
pu prédire peut-être vous André André
nous dit bon la crise énergétique
alors
l'énergéticien politique est-ce que vous
êtes câblé avec des gens qui font de la
prospective parce que la crise avec les
Russes elle couvait puis au minimum on
est pouvait être persuadé que ça allait
se castagner avec les Russes à partir de
2015-2 2016 quand on a vu les enclais se
déployant en Europe
pour faire du contrediscours ou pseudo
contre disciscours à partir de 2016
financé à coup de million d'euros un peu
des cluster un peu partout quand vous
les politiciens et vous les ingénieurs
on va laisser tranquille les ingénieurs
tranquilles par qu' en général leur
bou pas tout de suite s'il vous plaît
monsieur Merlin je je pas tout de suite
s'il vous plaît monsieur Merlin. Je sais
que je parle trop et merci je vous le
donne tout de suite. Les politiciens,
les politiques pardon, ils sont
connectés avec des gens qui font de la
prospective où ils ont juste le nez dans
leur mandat et puis ils attendent que
les courses se continue et que ça
s'empile pas trop sous le tapis. On est
connecté, on est connecté, on a une
délégation d'ailleurs au Sénat à la
prospective euh donc qui travaille, qui
rencontre beaucoup de personnes. Alors
après, des réunions aussi. Bah, on fait
forcément des réunions. Vous savez, la
Réunion Nite, c'est c'est quelque chose
qui est très répandu dans dans le pays
un peu partout et pas uniquement chez
les politiques. Mis à part leur titre,
ils ont des trophées ou pas ? C'estd que
c'est bien beau de faire de la
prospective, des réunions, ainsi de
suite. Est-ce qu'ils ont déjà anticipé
quelque chose ? Alors, attendez,
attendez, c'est une délégation à la
prospective. Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
cette délégation ? Elle rencontre pas
mal de de personnes qui qui sont censées
faire la prospective. Alors après il y
en a des bons, il y en a des moins bons.
Vous avez pas là- 156 milliards de
balance commercial, ils ont rencontré
que les mauvais hein. Ils ont sans doute
rencontrer que les mauvais. Mais si vous
euh si vous dites que c'est dégation
prospective qui qui est qui est en en
responsabilité sur le déficit commercial
de la France, c'est quand même un peu un
peu Non mais infiné si vous êtes pas
capable d'anticiper, donc de gouverner
donc de
prévoir on gouverne rien. Vous savez
Attendez, mais vous vous pensez qu'on
gouverne quoi ? Vous vous savez sur un
budget le budget de la France, vous
savez ce que le la représentation
nationale peut faire bouger ? Une
feuille de papier à cigarette, c'est
moins d' 1 %. Moins d' 1 %. Vous pouvez
regarder chaque année, vous regardez
donc qui décide qui décide des budgets,
c'est le gouvernement. Mais le
gouvernement avec l'administration, avec
Ber c'est Mercy qui fait ce qui qui fait
le budget et derrière c'est eux qui
l'appliquent. Et euh nous nous
honnêtement, c'est un des problèmes de
la France hein, si on pouvait parler des
problèmes d'institution et autres parce
que on a un président de la République
qui a des pouvoir considérable par
rapport à toute démocratie. Il y a il y
a pratiquement aucune démocratie dans le
monde qui a donné autant de pouvoir à
une seule personne. Donc c'est la
France. Et on dit qu'on est un régime
parlementaire, mais en réalité le
Parlement, on décide de quasiment rien.
Vous gagnez combien par mois et et ça en
net ou en brut ? Ah bah bien sûr en net.
En net hein, c'est ce que Alors, après
un pot ou avant un pot, bah ça dépend.
Ça dépend. Non, mais moi je touche en a
4400 €. Voilà, 4400 € par mois et en net
euh voilà après impôt. 4400 € pour gérer
1 % ça fait peut-être un peu beaucoup.
Non, ça fait beaucoup vous trouvez ? Je
sais pas. Je sais pas. Moi moi quand
j'en parle à des amis qui sont qui
travaillent en entreprise, qui sont
chefs d'entreprise ou autres, ils ont
pas trop envie de s'investir en
politique quand je leur parle de la
rémunération que que l'on touche.
Honnêtement, moi j'ai quand même
beaucoup d'amis qui bon j'ai un certain
âge, hein. J'ai quand même maintenant 43
ans de travail derrière moi. Donc je
vais encore continuer un petit peu mais
je sais pas combien de temps. Mais
honnêtement, je trouve pas que en fin de
carrière entre guillemets ça soit un
salaire remarquable. La prospective. Non
mais non mais la la prospective c'est
quelque chose qui malheureusement n'est
pas assez répandu. On on dit dans le
monde politique mais pas uniquement dans
le monde politique. Mais euh moi je le
vois avec t tous les tous les
ministères. Moi, j'ai travaillé beaucoup
sur le ministère des affaires étrangères
que vous connaissez bien le ministère
des affaires étrangères. Quand vous leur
demandez des notes stratégique sur
l'avenir, sur le leurs orientations
d'avenir, il y a rien. Vous avez
l'expression
non ? Des notes stratégiques. Des notes
stratégiques. On fait remonter des notes
aussi pertinentes qu'un filède parce
qu'en fait, pardonnez-moi l'expression,
pas de couille, pas d'embrouille. Bah
voilà,
j'avais pas cette expression en tête
mais elle est bonne. Mais en en réalité
en réalité vous apercevez que derrière
il y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
réfléchissent vraiment à la prospective
et qu'est-ce que ça va être dans 10 ans,
15 ans, 30
ans et c'est ce qui nous manque
beaucoup. Monsieur Merlin, écoutez, moi
je pense que on s'adresse pas toujours
aux bonnes personnes. C'estàd que le je
crois que le choix des conseillers à mon
avis au niveau de des du gouvernement à
mon avis n'est pas le meilleur qu'il
soit. Enfin, ça c'est sur mon point de
vue personnel. Ce que je voudrais dire
surtout, c'est que si la crise
énergétique qu'on a connu, il y a un
facteur majeur qui est lié euh au risque
qu'a pris l'Allemagne d'être beaucoup
trop dépendant du gaz russe. Et c'est
effectivement à cause de ça, c'est un
des facteurs qui a
provoqué l'explosion du prix de du gaz
mais aussi de l'électricité parce que
bien évidemment hein alors il y a eu un
deuxième facteur qui était le fait que
cette année-là on avait une hydraulicité
qui était qui était faible et notamment
les pays nordiques ont eu un peu de de
mal de ce point de vue-là et le tr le
parc était boîteux et le troisème
effectivement c'est le parc nucléaire
avec les la corrosion sous contrainte,
on aurait dû effectivement et c'est là
où les stratèges n'ont peut-être pas
suffisamment sont pas intervenu, je sais
pas pourquoi, c'est peut-être des
astrologues et écoutez, étant donné que
ces ces ces centres ces réacteurs ont
été construits en série, bien évidemment
il y avait des risques effectivement que
il y ait plusieurs réacteurs en même
temps qui soient affectés et ça a été le
cas.
Et ce qui a pas été dit, je sais pas si
ça a été dit lors de la la commission
d'enquête, soit l'Assemblée nationale,
soit le Sénat, c'est qu'entre 12 et
2020, tenez-vous bien, on a mis à la
casse 10 GW de centrale thermique
classique, c'est qui fonctionnait bien
évidemment au charbon au fioule, mais
qui était une réserve à l'arrêt qui ne
produisait aucun gaz à effet de serre,
était là uniquement en
au cas où c'est notre groupe électrogène
Oui, exactement exactement donc si vous
voulez arrêter 10 GW uniquement parce
que en en terme de communication ça fait
bien on veut être les meilleurs au
niveau européen en ce qui concerne la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre effectivement ça ça frappe
l'opinion mais dans les faits ça sert à
rien au contraire ça fragilisé la France
qui a été obligée pendant la crise énerg
énergétique de d'importer de
l'électricité produite par les
Allemands, tenez-vous bien, avec du
linite, du mauvais charbon qui pollue
non seulement qui dégage CO2, mais qui
pollue toute toute l'Europe en particul
en particulier du soufre non pardon avec
du soufre. Ouais, les particules souffr
et de la line. Non, je me trompe
peut-être. limite. Oui, la linite c'est
du charbon sale quoi. C'est c'est clair.
Et et en qui
plus cette électricité produite à partir
d'une nous a été vendu à un prix très
élevé. Et effectivement ce qui a fait
dire à beaucoup de responsables mais
pourquoi en France on a un marché
d'électricité avec des prix qui sont
corrélés au prix du charbon ou au prix
du gaz ? C'est à cause de ça. On aurait
dû garder cette réserve à l'arrêt. On
l'a démantelé. On l'a démantelé. Alors,
c'est des politiques ou des politiciens
ces gens-là ? Selon l'ingénieur ? À mon
avis, l'administration n'a pas joué le
rôle qu'elle aurait dû jouer parce
qu'elle aurait dû émettre un signal
d'alerte. D'ailleurs, lors de la
commission d'enquête de l'Assemblée
nationale sur la souveraineté
énergétique, un des responsables au
fonctionnaire a dit "Oui, on aurait dû
effectivement mettre ces ces moyens de
production sous cocon, c'est les mettre
en réserve en quelque sorte et en et les
redémarrer en situation mais on l'a pas
fait." Donc si vous voulez, c'est la
conjonction de tous ces facteurs qui ont
produit effectivement cette crise. Bon,
monsieur Merlin, il tape à coup de
Merlin là. Qu'est-ce qu'il peut dire
monsieur le sénateur ? Moi je me sens
pas trop
visé. Visé par par André. Non non mais
vous essayez de mettre un coin entre
nous deux mais ça se passe ça se passe
pas mal. Ça se passe pas mal mais euh
non simplement c'est vrai qu'en matière
énergétique et on a fait quand même des
grosses erreurs. La fermeture de F
français ça s'appelle comment ?
Superfénix. Il y a pas des grosses
erreurs. On a fait de la
politique. Merde la
merde. Moi, j'aurais pas dit ça comme
ça. J'aurais j'aurais pas dit ça comme
ça. Mais mais en tout cas en tout cas,
on a fait des énormes erreurs. Super
Phenniix, Astrid, Fenheim. Euh ça a
coûté combien tout ça
? Ça fait cher le kilo quand même non ?
Moi je considère c'est 5 milliards au
moins de de perte de valeur. Faenheim
c'est 5 milliards parce qu'on aurait pu
prolonger de 20 ans. Tous les travaux
avaient été faits je crois ou en grande
partie hein. C'est une décision purement
politique qui a coûté 5 milliards
d'euros. hein, c'est clair et peut-être
plus hein, il faudrait faire un calcul
plus précis mais c'est au moins cette
ordre de grandeur. Non non, c'est c'est
assez fou et c'est effectivement les
centrales les centrales thermiques
plutôt que de les garder en disant euh
on a si on en a besoin à un moment donné
euh il faudrait il faut on pourra les
les réactiver. Effectivement aujourd'hui
il faudrait réinvestir un peu dans
certaines centrales thermiques. Nous
nous on l'a dit en tout cas sur dans
notre commission d'enquête, on l'a dit
sur le gaz notamment au gaz et au biogaz
hein puisque et on on aurait besoin
aujourd'hui d'avoir cela. pour justement
ne pas aller trop vite euh sur les
énergies renouvelables et attendre un
peu de voir comment ça se passe parce
que en fait ce qu'on arrive du on a
beaucoup de mal anticipé. Alors euh la
prospective c'est c'est pas facile hein,
c'est en général pas facile mais sur
l'électricité c'est compliqué parce que
depuis 15 ans, on l'a dit tout à
l'heure, la consommation électrique a
plutôt baissé. Ça fait 15 ans alors
qu'on pensait qu'elle allait monter,
elle allait progresser. Et là ça ça fait
ça fait quelques années qu'on nous dit
ça va décoller, ça va décoller et en
fait ça décolle pas. Ça décolle pas.
Donc à quel moment ça va décoller ? Vous
qui êtes très fort en prospective, vous
pourrez peut-être nous le dire, mais en
fait nous je peux vous dire simplement
que si la courbe de consommation
énergétique descend, ça veut dire que le
pays est en récession. On on crame on
crame les Chinois comme ça.
Merche vous savez ce qui nous permet de
pas être en récession en France ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait la croissance ? La
dette. Oui, la dépense publique. Parce
que parce que la dépense publique c'est
elle qui agit beaucoup sur la
croissance. C'est l'énergie magique et
et et pour payer la dépense publique, on
s'endette. Et ça veut dire que en France
plus plus on s'endettete, plus on
s'enrichit en fait. C'est ça. Vous
comprenez ? Et c'est c'est quand même un
par c'est quand même quelque chose d'un
peu bizarre. Et vous avez trouvé ça sous
le pied d'un cheval ? Ça c'est ça
c'était dans mon bouquin que j'ai offert
à Bonoau Lemire. Donc j'essayé de lui
expliquer comment ça se passait et les
raisonnements qu'on faisait qui étaient
quand même très mauvais. Donc il faut à
un moment donné revenir un peu les pieds
sur terre et effectivement essayer de
faire des choix qui soient des choix
rationnels. Moi je le redis. Monsieur
Merlin, en tant qu'ingénieur, quand je
vous dis la dette c'est de l'énergie
magique. La dette c'est
c'est la solution des politique pour
masquer la récession. Oui, moi je je pas
je suis pas un financier, je pas j'ai
jamais mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord. C'est effectivement la la
dette qui a mais aujourd'hui on est au
bout au bout du rouleau quoi. On peut
pas aller au-delà. Donc ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est effectivement faire de
prendre de bonnes décisions qui évitent
de gaspiller l'argent public. Alors le
taureau par les cornes. Monsieur le le
sénateur, est-ce que notre gouvernement,
notre administration a compris que la
sève de notre industrie, c'est notre
compétitivité énergétique où ils vont
ils vont continuer à sauver les bébés
FOC et puis à décarbonner alors que les
Chinois, les Indiens, les Indiens ont
produit l'année dernière un milliard de
tonnes de charbon. Tranquille. Les
Chinois, ils produisent l'équivalent de
plus de 100 millions de barils par jour
de pétrole. Euh euh non, excusez-moi,
euh 12 millions de barils de pétrole par
jour équivalent de charbon. De ce qui
produisent en charbon, c'est 12 millions
de baril de pétrole. Je demande à à FA
checké et on se réveille quand ? On
prend le taureau par les cornes, on se
redresse les manches, on se sort les
doigts ou on continue de rester à faire
des chèqus en blanc ? Non, écoutez, le
premier ministre est exprimé à la fois à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat sur le
débat sur la programmation pluriannuelle
de
l'énergie. On va voir ce qui va en
sortir parce que il a dit, il se donnait
jusqu'à l'été pour faire les choix.
Je pense qu'il est quand même dans une
optique un peu plus réaliste et que que
n'étaient ses prédécesseurs sur le sujet
et beaucoup moins idéologique. Donc il
on l'a senti à l'écoute et je peux vous
dire que le travail qu'on a fait au
Sénat, alors à l'Assemblée nationale,
j'ai
moins peut-être moins de retour mais moi
j'ai j'ai je veux pas taper sur
l'Assemblée nationale mais je pense que
aujourd'hui le Sénat est plus à même de
travailler sur le fond des dossiers que
l'Assemblée nationale. tenu de sa
composition, l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui, elle a du mal à aller
vraiment sur les sujets de fond alors
que nous nous y parvenons. Donc sur sur
le sur l'électricité comme sur pas mal
d'autres sujets, on va vraiment au fond
des problèmes et si le gouvernement euh
si le premier ministre a tenu les propos
qu'il a tenu au Sénat, c'est aussi parce
qu'on l'a alerté en amont. Donc je pense
que ça devrait ça devrait avoir une
influence. Ceci étant, ceci étant
aujourd'hui, si vous êtes capable de
faire passer quelque chose à l'Assemblée
nationale, vous me le dites parce que
avec l'absence de majorité, je pense que
il y a pas grand-chose qui peut passer
malheureusement. Comment le 493, ça
passe bien avec un 493 ? 493, ça passe
avec une censure aujourd'hui sur pas mal
de sujets, ça peut passer avec censure
parce que quand vous avez quand vous
avez une conjonction de de gens qui pour
des raisons diverses parfois opposé mais
qui se retrouvent sur le même sur la
même ligne, ça peut refaire une deuxième
censure. Moi je c'est ce que je pense
qu'il va se passer avant la fin de
l'année. Donc en réalité la difficulté
alors la PPE elle passera peut-être
parce que comme elle peut passer quand
même par décret peut-être queelle va
passer à l'été en étant modifier par des
cré ce qui serait déjà un moindre mal je
pense moi pour moi. Mais derrière à
l'assemblée ça ne passera pas. Il y a
plein de choses qui ne passeront pas.
Avant de parler d'intelligence
artificielle et de consommation
énergétique liée à l'intelligence
artificielle, je veux juste vous poser
une question.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand les peuples
sont exposés à un sevrage énergétique ?
Politiquement parlant, il se passe quoi
à chaque
fois quand il y a une décroissance de la
consommation énergétique politiquement,
ça va vers quelle tendance ? Bah
forcément plutôt vers les extrêmes que
ça ne favorise pas ça ne favorise pas
le je dirais je vois pas le fond de
votre question. Alors je vous la fais en
simple. Ouais, parce que quand il n'y a
plus de foin dans les rateliers, les
chevaux se battent.
Oui, c'est la guerre civile
et en tout cas en tout cas moi je je
pense que alors moi je suis pas du tout
un adapté de la décroissance qu'on soit
bien clair je pense que la décroissance
c'est effectivement on risque d'affamer
les gens encore plus qu' ne le sont
aujourd'hui et d'aller vers des conflits
majeurs. Donc je pense qu'il faut
surtout pas prenez la décroissance et
c'est là où je suis un petit peu en
désaccord avec Jean Covici que j'aime
bien par ailleurs et qui qui est
quelqu'un de très intelligent et qui
mais je pense que dans nos sociétés
développées, on peut avoir de la
croissance en essayant de d'avoir un
petit peu moins de consommation
énergétique. Finalement, c'est ce qu'il
faut faire. Il faut développer
l'électricité mais il faut en même temps
aussi réussir à faire des économies par
ailleurs parce que sinon on n'y arrivera
jamais on n'arrivera jamais à atteindre
les objectif qu'on s'est fixé. Objectif
qu'il faut pas confondre avec la
réalité, avec ce qu'on est capable de
faire parce que souvent on confond les
deux hein, on confond les objectifs et
les capacités de les atteindre. Donc il
faut pas le faire. Les limites
physiques, monsieur Merlin, pardon. Vous
connaissez monsieur Jean Covici ? Oui,
je le connais très bien. Oui, il y a je
partage son point de vue sur le
nucléaire parce qu'il est favorable au
nucléaire comme amortisseur. Euh oui.
Euh mais je pense qu'il a des objectifs
qui me paraît enfin des une vision par
exemple de sur le les énergies fossiles
qui me paraît pas très pas juste quoi.
C'est c'està dire
que la situation est pas celle-là quoi.
Actuellement il y a encore beaucoup de
pétrole et beaucoup de gaz. Quel à quel
prix ? Bah le prix euh si vous voulez
vous voyez ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis. Drill baby drill. Ouais. Je
veux pas donc si vous voulez on n'est
pas dans la situation telle qu'il l'a
décrit. hein, c'est là où je diverge et
effectivement, il est favorable à la
décroissance et c'est pas une c'est pas
la solution que pour régler nos
problèmes. Et si et si s'il a raison ?
Je pense pas pour le moment, je pense
pas qu'il ait raison. C'est ça que c'est
c'est là où je diverge avec lui. Si s'il
a raison, s'il a raison, il faut qu'il
nous explique. Alors moi moi je l'ai je
l'ai invité à Massi, il est venu à
animer une réunion avec les élus. C'est
sympa Massie. C'est super sympa et euh
je vous y invite hein, vous pouvez me
dire surtout si vous jouez au rugby,
vous avez vous avez adoré. Vous avez
remarqué, vous avez adoré ça. Mais euh
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Moi moi
j'ai l'habitude euh d'offrir un livre au
à mes aux maires qui de laisson. J'ai à
peu près 200 maires un petit peu moins.
Mais je leur offre à Noël un bouquin.
C'est imprimé avec vos sous, hein ?
C'est imprimé avec mes sous. Et non,
c'est pas un primé avec mes sous, c'est
c'est moi qui les achète et je leur
offre je leur offre un livre que j'ai lu
dans l'année qui m'a plu et euh donc je
leur envoie. Et cette cette année-là,
j'avais j'avais dit le monde sans fin,
ça me paraît ça me paraît très bien. Je
l'avais pas lu mais on m'en avait parlé.
Donc je me suis dit tiens, le monde sans
fin, allons-y. Euh euh et du coup j'en
ai commandé 250. Combien ça vous a coûté
?
250 c'était 31 € euh le truc je sais
plus hein. Vous faites vous faites le
C'est c'est quand même pas pas
complètement négligeable. Il y a combien
de zéos à 1 milliard ? Ça faisait pas 1
milliard là. Il y a combien de zéro à 1
milliard ? 1 milliard ça veille à 9 90
ça vous va 7750 € comment 7 7750 € 7550
voilà et euh merci merci pour le et euh
j'en avais commandé donc euh et quand
ils sont arrivés moi je les avais pas
vu. Je pensais que c'était des tintins
stérix une bande dessinée. Je me suis je
m'étais dit et j'ai vu arriver les
palettes dans mon bureau les 250. Je me
suis dit mais je peux pas envoyer ça, ça
va me coûter déjà une blinde de de
d'envoyer le truc. Et puis euh les gars,
ils vont dire "Vincent, il est tombé sur
la tête là et qu'est-ce qu'il lui prend
?" Euh et donc qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ?
Je me suis dit "Ben, je vais inviter
Jean-Marc Jeancovici à venir faire une
petite conférence et là je ferais
dédicacer
les et j'ai eu 300 personnes à la
conférence et donc tout le monde était
content d'avoir sa BD dédicacée par Jean
Coviciou et euh voilà donc il en a vendu
1 million. Oui oui oui oui, je sais je
sais je sais ça alors que au départ
c'était alors il a il a bénéficié aussi
de la conjoncture hein du fait qu'il y a
une crise énergétique ça a aidé aussi
mais il a il a réussi à expliquer un
sujet quand même très compliqué avec
beaucoup d'humour et quand même à à
faire passer des messages mais
mais là où je je dis comment on fait et
quand on lui pose la question comment on
fait parce qu'il a un très bon
diagnostic il vous explique les les
choses t Mais comment on fait après pour
expliquer parce que après c'est nous les
politiques qui devons expliquer aux gens
en leur disant "Attendez, il faut la
décroissance. Vous savez ce que ça va
faire sur vous ? Qu'est-ce que quelles
conséquences ça va avoir sur votre vie
quotidienne ? Sur vos revenus, sur tout
ça et euh comment comment on fait ?" Et
moi, je je lu posé clairement la
question à Jean-Marcovici, mais
là-dessus, il a pas de réponse, hein.
Pourtant, il est assez locas sur pas mal
de sujets. Mais euh quand il faut dire
comment on y arrive parce que il faut on
est en démocratie hein, donc il y a on
est il y a pas il y a il y a il y a pour
l'instant on est en démocratie. S'il y
avait un dictateur bienveillant, ça
serait peut-être idéal, mais euh c'est
rare les dictateurs bienveillants, il y
en a pas beaucoup dans le monde, hein.
Donc il y en a pas d'ailleurs. Il y en a
eu j'ai j'ai un gendre qui est
franco-éthiopien. Il m'a dit qu'en
Éthiopie pendant 10 ans, il y avait eu
un un dictateur bienveillant qui qui
avait le sens de l'intérêt général et
qui l'acier. Non non, c'était avant j'ai
mais j'ai plus le nom mais bon ce ce
ceci
étant non ce ceci étant on est en
démocratie et en démocratie il faut
arriver à se faire réélir et déjà se
faire réir et ensuite à se faire réélir.
Et si vous dites au aux gens si vous
leur expliquez, attendez, bon, vous vous
vivez pas toujours tous très bien, mais
il va falloir tous se serrer la ceinture
beaucoup plus et avoir des perspectives
de décroissance, donc de moindre
richesse pour tout le monde parce que
c'est tout le monde qui est touché.
C'est très compliqué à expliquer. Donc
moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
c'est si j'avais une question à poser à
Jean-Marc Jeancovic là ici devant vous,
c'est lui dire comment on fait, comment
on fait. Je vous pose une question.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêt à arrêter de
vendre du rêve ?
Moi, j'ai jamais vendu de rêve. Le le
donc j'ai honnêtement pour ma part, j'ai
jamais vendu de rêve. Moi quand j'ai dit
à Massie on doit faire des efforts, j'ai
demandé à tout le monde de faire des
efforts et voilà, j'ai développé la
ville, j'ai expliqué comment on
développer la ville. J'ai j'ai pas eu
l'impression de vendre du rêve à aucun
moment. Alors, c'est vrai que de temps
en temps, on se dit il faut pour être
élu, il faut vendre du rêve. Moi, je je
préfère être réaliste, honnête, sincère
et montrer que bon, on peut agir, on est
là pour agir pour les gens, mais on le
fait avec eux. On le fait pas sans eux.
Et euh on leur explique moi j'ai vous
savez, j'ai j'ai construit beaucoup de
logements à Massie. J'ai il m'est arrivé
de construire 1000 logements par an.
Donc 1000 logements par an, ça fait
quand même pas mal. Donc j'étais style
maire bâtisseur. Mire bâtisseur. Il y a
pas mal de gens qui disent le maire
bâtisseur, on en veut pas. Tata. Bon,
j'ai j'ai beaucoup discuté avec les
gens, mais je faisais parfois 7 h
réunions sur un projet parce que à
chaque fois, j'essayais d'expliquer, de
convaincre, je revenais, je discutais,
je je bougeais. Mais si vous êtes
immobile et si vous vendez du rêve et
qu'après les gens ils s'aperçoivent que
vous les avez complètement dupé, c'est
là où c'est catastrophique. Là, vous
avez plus aucune confiance après dans
les politiques et autres. Donc moi, je
pense qu'il faut pas vendre du rêve, il
faut être
réaliste. Quand il faut expliquer
quelque chose, il faut être aussi
courageux. Le courage, ça manque
beaucoup en politique, c'est ce qui
manque le plus. Souvent, moi quand je
propose des je fais des propositions à
mes collègues, ils me disent "Mais
attends, ça va jamais passer, c'est les
gens vont jamais vouloir." Mais si
onxlique pas aux gens effectivement ça
passe pas. Si vous leur dites qu'il
faudrait augmenter la TVA et baisser la
CSG, ben bien sûr, les gens au début,
ils voient que la la l'augmentation de
la TVA, ils se disent "ça va pas." Mais
si vous leur expliquez bien pourquoi
vous on pourrait le faire et pourquoi ça
serait intéressant économiquement de le
faire, moi je suis sûr qu'on peut euh
trouver des des gens qui vous écoutent.
Moi, je suis plutôt pour des impôts
assez bass. Je suis plutôt pour limiter
la dépense publique et faire en sorte
qu'on ait des impôts plus bas. Moi, moi
aussi et puis je crois au Père Noël.
Vous croyez au père Noël ? Mais moi je
je crois je crois j'ai cru à mon au père
Noël, mais ça fait quand même un petit
moment que j'ai j'y crois plus. Mais euh
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à Massie ?
J'ai j'ai voulu faire un quartier euh un
nouveau quartier. J'avais pas de
terrain, j'avais pas beaucoup d'argent
et euh qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ? J'ai
dit au propriétaires des terrains,
c'était des entreprises, je leur ai dit,
je vous donne de la valeur à votre
terrain, je vais vous permettre de
construire plus mais je vais récupérer
une partie de cette valeur pour financer
toutes mes rues, toutes mes réseaux,
tout ça. Et au début, ils m'ont dit
"Monsieur le maire, pas facile." Mais
finalement, ils ont accepté et
finalement j'ai fait des dosanes, j'ai
récupéré 140 millions. J'ai r 140
millions pour faire des voiries, des
réseaux, tout le quartier. Et c'est pas
le contribuable qui a payé. Donc c'est
les les entreprises, les propriétaires
qui ont payé. Donc je pense qu'il y a
une logique aussi économique parfois
qu'on peut expliquer même si c'est pas
toujours facile, on peut expliquer des
choses aux gens. Et voilà. Monsieur
Merlin, est-ce que les politiques
comprennent le principe d'instabilité
dans les systèmes à thermodynamique ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il y a une
instabilité dans la thermodynamique ?
Là, il le découvre, je pense, et et je
pense que actuellement la Commission
européenne est très embêtée de voir ce
qui s'est passé péninsul ibérique parce
que si vous voulez, ça va obliger à
consommer davantage de
gaz, je dis pas du charbon mais au moins
du gaz parce que pour rééquilibrer le
système, il faut qu'il y ait davantage
de moyens de production pilotable et
moins de production intermittente. Donc
c'est ce que fait actuellement
d'ailleurs le la péninsule ibérique. Ils
produisent davantage d'électricité pour
restabiliser le système. Donc imaginez
que avec
uniquement des renouvelables
intermittents
et du gaz, on pourra atteindre en 2050
la neutralité carbone. À mon avis, c'est
c'est c'est du rêve. Voilà, c'est
exactement. Et ça va devenir
effectivement ça va
s'imposer au à la future Commission
européenne. Peut-être pas celle celle-là
mais celle qui va suivre. C'est présidé
par Emmanuel Macron. J'en sais rien. On
verra. On verra. On verra. Ah vous
pensez que c'est la suite ? Ah non je
pense que c'est ce qu'il vise. J'en sais
rien. J'en sais s'il fait ce qu'il a
fait jusqu'à présent je cra il faudra
peut-être attendre le suivant.
On mangera les picans lit par la racine
d'ici là. Oui, l'industrie
française qui est en train de se
positionner. Il y a notre Vernia préféré
qui dit "Bon bah ça devient compliqué
moi d'entreprendre et de produire en
France avec le coût de l'énergie.
Compliqué. On voit la consommation
énergétique française qui stagne
monsieur Marlin depuis 2012. Depuis
quand elle stagne ? Elle descend. On est
à hauteur de 2003. Ça a commencé à
partir de 2012. C'est ça. 2012. Ça ça a
baissé
de lentement mais à partir de 2012. et
on retrouve le niveau de consommation de
2003. Et et à mon avis, il y a deux
facteurs qui ont joué là-dessus. Enfin,
je sais pas si Vincent portage mon point
de vue, c'est l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité. Ah, c'est et il y a une
augmentation entre 2008 et 2020. Je je
mets de côté la crise, hein, mais 2020,
tenez-vous bien, de 60 % au moins en
euroconstant. Rendez compte ? 60 %.
Alors que avant, entre 96 et 2008, le
prix de l'électricité euro constant
avait baissé de 20
%. Bon, donc si vous voulez, le prix de
l'électricité augmentant, bah les gens
font des économies d'électricité. Moi,
je connais des familles qui ne chauffent
qu'une qu'une qu'une pièce l'hiver parce
que ça ça leur fait beaucoup trop de
charge. Quand j'ai été interviewé sur
une radio nationale, une personne qui
m'a dit "Ouais, c'est très bien
effectivement, mais euh aujourd'hui,
j'ai fait les travaux d'isolement de ma
maison et je paye une facture
d'électricité plus importante que celle
que j'avais avant." Rendez compte ? Donc
ça c'est le premier facteur, c'est
l'augmentation du prix. Et le 2e
effectivement c'est la réduction de
l'activité
industrielle, c'est-à-dire en fait euh
la désindustrialisation qu'on a connu,
hein, qui aussi qui est quand même lié
qui est quand même lié à au taxes qu'on
a en France euh parce que la fiscalité
la fiscalité est très lourde en France.
Pourquoi elle est lourde ? Parce que
parce qu'on a beaucoup de dépenses hein
et et même avec cette fiscalité lourde,
on narrive pas à équilibrer nos budgets
parce qu'on est en déficit, qu'on a une
dette qui augmente de façon
considérable. Donc la première des
choses à faire, c'est de réduire la
dépense. Et on a un système social. Moi,
je parle surtout pas de modèle parce que
le modèle c'est quelque chose qui est
copié. J'ai toujours appris ça à
l'école. Euh quand on a un modèle, on le
copie. Donc en France, on parle de
modèle social alors que personne nous
copie. Donc on a un système social qui
est très généreux et qui effectivement
coûte très très cher et du coup pèse
beaucoup sur les entreprises, les
entreprises de production hein quand on
a quand on doit produire les entreprises
industrielles elles produisent. Et euh
du coup les les le coût le coût de la
production est énorme. Donc il y a eu
des efforts de fait hein, il y a eu des
baisses de d'impôts de production, il
faut le reconnaître. Le problème c'est
qu'on baisse les impôts de production
sans baisser la dépense. Donc en fait on
finance par de la dette et on va finir
par retrouver parce que le poids de la
dette c'est une chose, c'est surtout les
intérêts de la dette. Les intérêts de la
dette, ça allait quand les taux
d'intérêt étaient à zéro. Aujourd'hui
ils sont plus à zéro et aujourd'hui on
on a des taux d'intérêt qui sont plus
élevés que l'Espagne et le Portugal. On
parlait de la pédulé, on disait les
espagnols et les Portugais, il y a
quelques années, on s'emboquait un petit
peu. On disait "Attendez, vous voyez
dans quelle situation ils sont."
Aujourd'hui, c'est nous qui sommes dans
cette situation là. Comment on les a on
les a appelé à l'époque ? Les pigs. Les
pigs. Ouais. Les pigs. Horrible. Tout à
fait. Tout à fait. Et euh et
aujourd'hui, ils sont mieux placés que
nous. La Grèce est presque mieux placée
que nous alors qu'ils ils ont été ils
ont ils ont dû subir un choc très
important. Donc nous, on ferait bien de
se méfier. Je pense que il serait temps
qu'on réagisse par rapport à cela. Il
est grand temps ça fait quelques années
que je j'interpelle le gouvernement sur
le sujet. Les gouvernements successifs
parce que ça a beaucoup bougé au niveau
gouvernemental. Ça ça bouge beaucoup.
Mais c'est sûr que le prix d'électricité
plus la fiscalité ça fait que on a des
entreprises qui même si elles sont très
performantes sont quand même pénalisées
fortement. Monsieur le sénateur,
monsieur Merlin, y compris les
Avernières, les meilleurs tout le
monde. Monsieur, je dis pas ça parce
qu'on a un overrien qui est devant nous.
Oui. Vous êtes relativement jeune tous
les deux ? Très jeune. Très jeune. Moi,
je dirais même.
Le pays, vous le sentez aller vers
quelle direction ? On commence pas à se
réveiller nous l'intelligence française.
Je voudrais le point de vue de
l'ingénieur et je voudrais ensuite le
point de vue du
sénateur. Écoutez, moi je pense que la
la France peut effectivement se se
redresser mais effectivement il
faut de nouvelles orientations et
j'espère que après les présidentiels
dans 2 ans, il y a un gouvernement qui
soit capable effectivement de redresser
notre pays comme l'a fait le général de
Gaul en en 58. C'est à peu près le le
même enjeu, hein. Je pense que je sais
pas moi j'ai j'ai quelques contacts qui
me laissent penser que par exemple il
faudrait proposer une réduction des
dépenses de l'ordre je dirais 170
milliards par an. Pas loin pas loin.
C'est et et c'est c'est l'effort qui va
falloir faire. Donc après, il faudra
effectivement l'expliquer aux français
et dire pour comment on peut réussir. Et
parmi ces la réduction de ces ces
dépenses, il y a bien évidemment la part
énergie. Monsieur le sénateur, alors je
juste sur sur les dépenses, il faut
savoir depu entre 2019 et 2024, moi j'ai
fait la comparaison des dépenses
publiques. 2019 c'était avant crise,
d'accord. Il y avait pas encore le
Covid, il y avait pas encore qu'il en
coûte. Donc on était pas encore les
Russes. Voilà, il y avait pas encore les
Russes. 2024, on peut dire qu'on était
après le quoi qu'il en coûte, même s'il
a mis du temps à s'éteindre. Euh 2024 et
on y était après. Vous savez de combien
euh c'est si si si la dépense publique
n'avait augmenté que euh la dépense de
l'État n'avait augmenté que de
l'inflation, ce qui était déjà pas mal
hein. Si on avait augmenté que de
l'inflation, combien on aurait économisé
aujourd'hui ? 120 milliards. Vous vous
rendez compte ? 120 milliards et on a un
déficit de 160 milliards. Donc vous
voyez, il y aurait un déficit que de 40
milliards, c'est déjà pas mal, mais ça
serait quand même déjà beaucoup plus
acceptable. Donc je pense qu'il y a un
laisser aller complet hein dans le pays
depuis depuis pas mal d'années
et il y a il y a il y a aucune rigueur.
On a un laxisme général et il faut quand
quand on gère l'argent public, moi j'ai
je suis j'ai j'ai aussi passé mon
diplôme d'expert comptable. Vous voyez,
je suis expert comptable. embrasse la et
je me sais je me sais traiter par mon
opposition dont Mélenchon de comptable.
Mélenchon, il me traitait de comptable
et tout ça. Pas là pour discuter cuisine
là. Pas pas cuisine. Je je dis ça parce
que je j'aime bien Jean-Luc Mélenchon
que j'ai que j'ai côtoyé pas mal.
Embrasse aussi mais vous l'embrassez si
vous avez envie. Moi je l'embrasse pas
mais pour que vous embrassez pas
Jean-Luc
parce que on s'est jamais embrassé. Donc
moi je je j'ai du respect pour tout le
monde mais je garde mes distances aussi
et notamment avec mon opposition. Et
quand il me traitait de comptable, moi
je leur disais, moi je suis désolé, moi
je ne connais qu'une façon de gérer de
l'argent public, c'est de la rigueur.
Donc l'argent public, c'est l'argent de
tous et on doit le gérer avec rigueur.
Qu'on fasse chacun ce qu'on a envie de
avec son argent, ça c'est son problème.
Mais l'argent de tous, il faut le gérer
avec rigur. Effectivement aujourd'hui la
France, la France, elle a quand même
énormément reculé. Elle a reculé dans le
la
richesse globale mais dans la richesse
par habitant considérable. Vous savez
qu'on est le 25e pays aujourd'hui euh au
monde dans la pour la richesse par
habitant. Donc quand on compare avec les
pays étrangers, il faut regarder aussi
quelle richesse on a par rapport aux
Allemands. On a 20 % de richesse par
habitant en moins. En moins imaginer
parce que ça c'est un message du
chiffre. Si on enlève Paris, on se
retrouve à quelle quelle distance
classement ? Je l'ai pas fait. Si on
enlève Paris, je l'ai pas fait. Mais si
vous si vous enlevez les métropoles,
vous allez voir que ça va dégringoler
énormément. Mais je je l'ai pas fait
hein, je je sais pas. Mais déjà 25e, je
trouve pas que ça soit brillant
honnêtement. C'est c'est pas brillant.
Donc aujourd'hui, c'est vrai qu'il y a
il y a un redressement à opérer. Moi je
sais pas s'il faut attendre 2 ans.
Personnellement
je je je vois pas je vois pas comment on
peut continuer à glisser sur la pente
dans laquelle sur laquelle on est sans
rien faire pendant 2 ans de plus. Voilà.
Moi le président de la République, il a
pas dit grand-chose l'autre jour. Il
était plutôt sur la défensive. J'aurais
aimé qu' qui trace quelques
perspectives, même si ça a pas l'air
d'être son souci premier aujourd'hui,
tracer les perspectives, mais on a
besoin de quelqu'un qui trace des
perspectives et qui nous montre
clairement comment on peut se redresser.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est c'est
indispensable d'aller dans cette
directionlà. On a quand même beaucoup
d'atout, hein. On a on a des très très
bons ingénieurs. C'est pas parce que
André est là que que je le dis, euh
c'est pas pour vous non plus, mais vous
en faites partie. Et on a on a des très
bons ingénieurs. On a on a quand même la
qualité. Il faut arriver à retenir notre
jeunesse en France. Faut arriver à
rendre à nouveau notre pays attractif
parce que OK, il y a qu'un faucon. Il y
a qu'un faucon. On peut on peut en
parler des heures. Ouais, grave. Euh
question l'intelligence artificielle. On
voit les États-Unis décréter l'énergie
comme urgence nationale. On voit les
Chinois commencer à lancer des
programmes 12 ou 14 réacteurs autorium.
On voit euh leur mix énergétique s'étoit
être velu sur l'éolien, le solaire,
l'hydraulique, le nucléaire, le biogaz
et qui monsieur Berlin, il dit de la
tête. Écoutez, moi moi je pense
que certes l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement j'ai commencé ma
carrière à direction de la recherche des
DF en faisant de l'intelligence
artificielle appliqué à l'aide à la
décision pour la planification et
l'exploitation des grands systèmes
électriques. je connais, j'ai j'ai
développé des algorithmes et puis
ensuite j'ai fait développer des
algorithmes par tous mes collaborateurs
et on a d'ailleurs eu beaucoup de
succès. Ça consomme effectivement
beaucoup de puissance de
calcul mais je pense pas que ça puisse
très
rapidement contrairement à ce que
certains disent augmenter comme Eric
Schmidth et d'autres pardon comme Eric
Schmidth et d'autres oui augmenter
rapidement la la consommation
d'électricité d'autant
que lorsqu'on veut construire des des
grands data centers on cherche d'abord
là où l'électricité est la moins chère
malheureusement
En Europe, elle est très chère, elle est
moins chère en France, il faut le
reconnaître. Mais ailleurs au Canada et
aux États-Unis, elle est beaucoup moins
chère. Et qui plus est, il faut
pouvoir climatiser ces centres de
données. Donc, on a tendance
effectivement à envisager de les
installer plutôt dans le nord. Vous
voyez ? Donc à mon avis, un des un des
des pays qui seraient le mieux placés
pour les data center, c'est le Canada.
C'est mon mon point de vue par bon, ce
qui n'empêche pas effectivement qu'il y
ait des datas centur en France, mais je
pense pas que ça puisse
effectivement permettre de d'atteindre
les objectifs tels que certains le
disent, c'estàd d'une augmentation de je
sais pas de 3 4 ou 5 % de de la
consommation d'électricité par an. Voilà
mon point de vue. Je peux me tromper
hein. Je pense monsieur le sénateur, moi
je pense que ça va participer quand même
à l'augmentation de la consommation
électrique hein. Ça ça me paraît assez
évident mais euh combien on en aura,
combien jusqu'où euh ça va aller
effectivement ? Mais euh je pense que la
proximité quand même dans la traitement
des données, c'est pas quelque chose qui
est complètement négligeable. Donc euh
on aura besoin aussi d'avoir des data
center non pas au qu'au Canada ou
ailleurs. On en aura on en aura en
France. et forcément, il faudra les
alimenter sur le plan énergétique. Ce
sera des data centers souverains. Tout à
fait. Question internet. Que pensez-vous
de la destruction des 241 barrages en
Espagne en 2021 et 2022 liés à lié à la
directive européenne ? Je j'ai pas
j'étais pas au courant. Non, non plus.
Question internet que je découvre avec
vous. Pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur le
débat autour des concessions
hydroélectriques en France ? On parle de
privatisation, de concession, de perte
de contrôle. Il me semble que c'est bien
le régime de concession qui permet à
l'État de garder la propriété des
barrages et d'en tirer profit grâce à
des appels d'offre. Oui. Alors moi je
pense sur ce point, je me permets de la
parole en premier. Euh donc sur le
problème de ces concessions, c'est
effectivement on est euh il y a une
directive qui oblige effectivement la
mise en concurrence des concessions à la
fin de de des concessions. Et la
conséquence, c'est que depuis
20 ans 20 ans environ, rien ne se passe
en France parce que
effectivement
un exploitant de moyen de production
hydraulique, il ne peut pas investir
s'il a pas la garantie effectivement
qu'il garde la la concession. Donc ce
qui est dommage c'est qu'effectivement
il y a plusieurs sites et en particulier
dans le pay d'où je viens où on pourrait
construire des station de transfert de
l'énergie par pompage qui est la
solution la plus euh efficace pour
stocker pour pouvoir euh stocker
l'électricité
et en cas de black de pouvoir redémarrer
dans les conditions les plus favorables.
La plus facilement, on peut les appeler
très facilement pour qu'il lâche un peu.
Ouais. Alors euh si vous voulez ce qui
la la question qui se pose effectivement
c'est comment on peut sortir de cette
situation ? Euh je pense que euh alors
je crois que le Séd il réfléchit. Il y a
eu des des même un rapport entre le le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale a fait un groupe
de travail sur le sujet. Voilà. Euh moi
mon sentiment c'est qu'il faudrait
sortir de la situation de concession et
de d'aller vers une un régime
d'autorisation, mais ça suppose
effectivement un transfert de propriété
vers le concessionnaire, que ce soit
EDF, que ce soit NG ou que ce soit une
une autre société. C'est une discussion
à voir avec la Commission européenne. Il
faut faire valoir notamment des
arguments juridiques, mais je pense que
ce serait une manière de sortir de de
cette cette situation qui à mon avis est
dommageable. Je partage tout à fait ce
point de vue d'André là, mais il est
urgent d'en sortir hein. Nous nous on a
rendu de notre rapport en juillet
dernier. On on disait déjà qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait accélérer sur le sujet de
l'hydroélectricité, essayer de trouver
comme un accord avec Bruxelles. En fait,
c'est c'est le désaccord avec Bruxelles
qui qui gèle la situation, qui gèle les
investissements et c'est des
investissements hyper rentables et sur
lesquels effectivement tout le monde
pourrait être d'accord très très vite.
Mais tant que ces concessions sont
bloquées parce que le renouvellement n'a
pas fait l'objet, en fait, il y a pas eu
de renouvellement.
comme on n'a pas fait de mise en
concurrence, il y a pas eu de
renouvellement de ces concessions. Ce
qui fait que sans sans renouvellement
des concessions, ben le concédent, le
concessionnaire, il a il a pas envie de
faire des travaux, quoi. Donc, on bloque
tout. Question internet. Pourquoi lancer
une production de PR2 à la complexité
redondante ? Est-il encore temps de
faire des réacteurs au torium ou des
surgénérateurs Astrides ?
Je crois qu'on a un peu répondu tout à
l'heure, c'est-à-dire que tant que le
prix de l'uranium est un niveau que l'on
connaît actuellement et même avec une
augmentation, je dirais même si le prix
de l'uranium doublé, il est toujours
intéressant d'avoir des réacteurs de
type PWR. Ce n'est que si effectivement
il y a une forte augmentation du prix de
l'iranium ou des problèmes de
disponibilité ou éventuellement oui que
effectivement il est nécessaire de
d'avoir la 4e génération c'est les
réacteurs à neuteron rapide. C'est pour
ça que dès maintenant il faut y aller.
Il faut y aller et c'est pour ça que la
décision de reprendre Astrid me paraît
tout à fait judicieuse. Et encore une
fois, on aurait dû ne pas arrêter le
projet à Astrid et on aurait pas dû
d'ailleurs à l'époque arrêter Superénus.
Question internet. Comment les Smart
Grid pourraient-il pourraient-elles
contribuer constituer des réponses
pertinentes face aux difficultés des
réseaux électriques ? Qu'est-ce que le
projet Hercule ou grand EDF ? ou où en
est-il ? Abandonné, renommé, enterré,
repoussé temporairement, définitivement
ressuscité et qu'en pensez-vous ? Alors
sur les Smart Grid, si vous voulez, euh
c'est un peu un rêve si je peux me
permettre. Il faut savoir que, je l'ai
pas dit, mais un système
électrique comme celui qu'on a en Europe
interconnecté est un système extrêmement
complexe. D'ailleurs, l'Académie des
ingénieurs des États-Unis a considéré
que au 21e siècle, c'est sans doute ce
qui est le ce qui a été le créé le plus
complexe et donc pour pouvoir faire
fonctionner la pensée d'Emmanuel de de
Bruno Lemire, je sais pas. Mais en tout
cas, ce que ce que l'on peut dire, c'est
que euh et je suis quand même assez bien
placé pour le dire, compte tenu de mes
mes débuts dans la recherche, un système
euh interconnecté électrique comme celui
en neuron ne peut marcher que si on a
effectivement des moyens informatiques
derrière qui permettent en particulier
de prendre les bonnes
décisions au niveau de l'exploitation du
notamment du du réseau. Donc si vous
voulez
l'informatique c'est une aide absolument
incontournable et d'ailleurs en plus on
a rajouté un marché d'électricité sur le
système interconnecté qui qui nécessite
encore plus d'informatique. Donc les
Smart Reid on sait ça existe déjà c'est
pas la peine. et et c'était
effectivement à un moment l'idée de dire
que ça permettra de
franchir une étape majeure, ce qui est
pas vrai. Ce qui est pas vrai. Donc les
Smart Grid à mon ami, on l' on les a
déjà. Alors en ce qui concerne le projet
Hercule, ça c'est un autre une autre
affaire. Ça c'est des c'est les
discussions avec la Commission
européenne euh pour savoir si on
doit découper EDF en morceaux. Non mais
on touche pas EDF. Et bien évidemment,
il y a une réticence très forte
notamment du personnel et en particulier
des syndicats pour aller dans cette
direction. Et je pense que je sais pas
si ce projet va être remis sur la table.
En tout cas, il avait été abandonné et
ça avait conduit en particulier le
monsieur LV de quitter DF. J'ai une
question spécialement pour vous,
monsieur Merlin. Je suis sûr que ça va
intéresser notre
sénateur. Ce ce cette grille hyper
complexe, est-ce que vous y avez vous
avez pensé au problèmes de type éruption
solaire ?
Oui. Euh c'est une question
effectivement que l'on s'est posée euh
mais qui euh n'a de de conséquences que
pour euh des réseaux qui sont orientés
nord-ud parce que l'effet
électromagnétique sur les lignes
électriques euh haute tension ne se
manifeste que s'il y a cette orientation
là. Si et donc euh il peut y avoir des
des effets euh disons euh néfastes
notamment au Canada parce que vous savez
qu'ils ont des moyens de production
hydraulique vraiment dans le nord du
Canada et effectivement ils ont eu des
problèmes de ce mais en Europe je
peut-être en Norvège encore mais mais en
Europe continentale je dirais il y a il
y a il y a pas de de risque majeur.
C'est pas ça le problème. Alors vous
Oui. Allez-y continuez. Non le le
problème c'est ce qu'on a vu en Espagne
et au Portugal, c'est
l'instabilité liée à des moyens non
pilotables qui ne contribuent nullement
à la stabilité du système électrique.
C'est ça le le risque principal et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut éviter d'aller dans
les proportions qui sont celles
proposées par la Commission européenne
au travers de du Green Deal. On a pas
parlé du Green Deal, on a beaucoup
critiqué le Green Deal pour la
l'agriculture. Pour l'énergie, c'est
aussi critical sinon plus hein. Et la
PPE, c'est une traduction du Green Deal
pour la France. Il faut bien le
comprendre. C'est ça. C'est
déraisonnable. Je vous laisse poser une
question à monsieur le sénateur. Bah,
écoutez, je je sais pas quel euh Moi, je
pense que ce qu'il faut effectivement
c'est euh assez vite aboutir à un une
PPE qui soit beaucoup plus raisonnable.
Et donc, est-ce que effectivement on
peut espérer, mais vous y avez déjà
répondu tout à l'heure, euh avoir un
accord d'ici la fin de cette
législature, quoi ? Moi, j'ai j'ai
répondu effectivement tout à l'heure que
j'espérais que ça sortirait à l'été, que
ça serait une copie nettement améliorée,
que le gouvernement arrivera à à mettre
sur la table à ce moment-là et tiendra
compte des travaux qui ont été faits.
Parce que moi, je ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure, on fait beaucoup de travaux à
l'Assemblée nationale, au Sénat beaucoup
aussi et on aime bien que en tout cas
pour moi, j'aime bien que nos travaux
soient suivis des faits et ne terminent
pas dans un tiroir. Donc on a fait 821
pages sur l'électricité, c'est bon,
c'est un travail assez complet. Ça
serait dommage que ça ne soit pas suivi
des faits sur pas mal de sujets. Il y a
beaucoup qu'on a pas abordé ce soir mais
euh qui qui sont aussi dans le dans le
rapport. Allez-y, allez-y, hein. Non,
non, mais euh je pense par exemple à la
connaissance, on parlait de données et
traitement des données. Il y a il y a
une connaissance, c'est la remontée des
informations des compteurs vers euh vers
le distributeur parce que c'est
aujourd'hui les données ne remontent que
si le client donne son accord. Alors
qu'en fait ça devrait être l'inverse.
C'est ce qu'on prône nous dans notre
dans notre rapport, c'est dire que c'est
automatique. La remontée est
automatique, sauf si le consommateur se
s'oppose à cette remontée. Donc c'est
pas lui qui qui prend l'initiative de la
remontée, c'est la remontée est
automatique. Mais il il peut bien sûr
chacun peut s'y opposer s'il a envie de
s'y opposer. Et ça ça permettrait quand
même d'avoir une connaissance bien plus
fine de la consommation et du coup de de
mieux affiner la production en face et
de de mettre en rapport le c'est ce
qu'on cherche toujours à faire sur de
façon assez complexe de mettre en
rapport la demande et l'offre à chaque
fois et à chaque moment de la journée.
Donc ça c'est quelque chose d'assez
fondamental mais simplement sur le fond
quand on travaille et je pense que
chacun chaque personne qui nous écoute
là doit doit avoir conscience de cela
aussi à titre personnel. On aime bien
que notre travail soit il soit pris en
compte et qu'il soit suivi des faits.
Donc sinon vous avez l'impression de
servir à rien. Bah complètement
complètement. Vous savez le nombre de
rapports qui qui termine dans des
tiroirs, il y en a quand même
énormément. On se demande où passe
l'argent à un moment donné. Moi, je
connais pas mal de de fonctionnaires qui
font des rapports et qui font des
rapports qui se terminent dans les
tiroirs. Donc ça sert strictement à
rien. Ça peut caler les portes. Ouais,
ça peut caler les portes, c'est vrai.
Mais honnêtement, c'est quand quand on
cherche de l'argent un peu partout. Donc
moi, j'ai fait un rapport sur les
autoroutes, j'ai fait un rapport sur
l'électricité et j'aime bien continuer à
parler de mes rapports parce que je je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera
à faire avancer les sujets. Question
internet que je découvre avec vous.
Quelles seraient les conséquences sur la
robustesse du réseau électrique
d'électricité français si les derniers
haut fourneaux français venaient à
disparaître
? Je sans penser que l'incidence serait
serait relativement faible he parce que
c'est pas c'est pas à mon
avis je je pense pas que ça puisse avoir
des conséquences majeures. C'est c'est
mon sentiment. Mais enfin bon, je peux
me tromper mais c'est je sais pas si
j'ai pas d'avis hein honnêtement je sais
pas. Le réchauffement climatique, vous
avez un avis ? Le nucléaire c'est la
solution. Écoutez le le réchauffement
climatique c'est une réalité. Je pense
qu'on peut pas le le le nier. La
question c'est quel est l'effort qu'on
doit faire alors que on est déjà le pays
en est un des pays développés qui émet
le moins de gaz à effet de serre. On est
actuellement, je crois la moitié de des
émissions que par rapport à l'Allemagne
par exemple. Je parle pas des États-Unis
ou de la Chine. Donc à mon avis, il
devrait y avoir une prise en en compte
de cette situation
qui on a déjà fait un effort
considérable. Je pense que c'est une
critique qu'on a faite effectivement par
rapport à notamment à l'Europe. L'Europe
nous a fixé des objectifs sans tenir
compte de la situation particulière que
l'on avait grâce au nucléaire. Et c'est
vrai que le nucléaire était une très
bonne une très bonne solution pour la
France et elle reste une très bonne
solution. Elle restera une très bonne
solution. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
réinvestir le nucléaire fortement. On a
parlé de pas mal de sujets, mais euh on
n'a pas dit qu'il fallait renforcer un
certain nombre de de réacteurs actuels,
hein, les réacteurs de 900. C'est sans
doute l'investissement le plus rentable
aujourd'hui, c'est de les booster un
petit peu. Alors, on peut pas les
booster tant que ça, mais on peut sans
doute rajouter
10 % ou à peu près de l'ordre de 10 % et
prolonger la durée de vie de de nos
centrales. Parce que pour ceux qui nous
écoutent, ils ont peut-être déjà entendu
parler de l'effet falaise. L'effet
falaise, c'était de dire effectivement,
il y avait 40 ans de durée de vie
initiale de nos de nos centrales. Comme
elles sont sorties dans les années 80
90, on se disait dans les années 2020
2030, on va avoir cet effet falaise. Et
le fait de repousser à 60 voire à 80
ans, parce que aux États-Unis, il y en a
quand même, peut-être qu'on pourra pas
les repousser tout à 80 ans mais il y en
a un certain nombre. Je pense que c'est
les investissements les plus rentables
aujourd'hui à réaliser. Euh j'en ai
parlé avec nos président de DF récemment
au téléphone puisqu'on a eu des échanges
avant ses auditions, son audition au
Sénat et je pense qu'il a bien
conscience que effectivement il faut il
faut investir très rapidement dans ce
domaineel. Monsieur le sénateur, dans
votre rapport, quels sont les points,
les trois points les plus importants qui
sont remontés et donc dont on n pas
encore évoqué le qu'on a pas
évoqué alors parce que là je viens vous
vous en évoquer trois
autres. Non, on a parlé de ce qu'il
fallait obtenir de l'Europe euh qu'on a
peut-être pas beaucoup évoqué. On l'a
évoqué un tout petit peu mais on a dit
que le nucléaire, il y avait l'alliance
du nucléaire qui qui commençait à se
remonter. Mais euh vous savez que
pendant un moment le nucléaire au niveau
européen c'était euh tabou. C'était un
sujet totalement tabou. Il fallait pas
l'aborder. Personne n'en voulait. Donc
ça commence à changer. Et sur ce sur cet
aspect-là, on a dit qu'il fallait qu'il
y ait des financements européens qui
puissent que que les financements
européens en fait partent du neutralité
technologique, que ça soit des de
l'éolien, du solaire ou du nucléaire. On
peut bénéficier que la Banque européenne
d'investissement puisse aussi financer
des programmes en occurrence. Et il y a
aussi un dispositif de de projets
importants dans lesquels on aimerait que
le nucléaire puisse s'inscrire. Donc on
a dit que c'était des axes qu'il fallait
que la France défende fortement au
niveau
européen. Alors c'est vrai que si
l'Allemagne commence à évoluer, ça va
nous aider un petit peu peut-être à
faire évoluer les autres. Mais euh c'est
important que euh on respecte cette les
choix les choix énergétiques qui sont
faits par chaque pays parce que ça aussi
c'était dans les traités initiaux et les
Européens ont un petit peu oublié cela.
Monsieur le sénateur, je peux vous
couper ? Bien sûr, je vais parler à
l'ingénieur. Ingénieur quand on a
Pierre, Paul Jacques, les Belges, les
Luxembourgeois, les Français, les
Irlandais, les Espagnols, les Portugais,
ils font chacun leur petit choix choix
de leur côté côté côté. Comment on fait
pour piloter tout ça d'une façon un
petit peu mature ?
Toute manière ce que dit le l'incens que
la politique énergétique est normalement
du ressort de chaque état. C'est pas au
niveau européen, c'est chaque état. Et
euh donc la Commission européenne
influence les choix énergétiques au
travers de des actions liées au climat
et ça des limites. C'est pour ça que
effectivement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure, il faut absolument obtenir la
neutralité technologique totale entre le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
intermittentes. Je parle pas du
l'hydraulique qui est qui est la la
meilleure manière de produire
l'électricité.
Et il y a un point sur lequel à mon avis
il faut se battre, c'est que dans le
fonctionnement du marché de
l'électricité au niveau européen, il y a
la priorité qui est donnée
systématiquement aux énergies
renouvelables intermittentes. Alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire que vous êtes obligé dans certains
cas de baisser la production de des
centrales nucléaires pour pouvoir
favoriser la production d'origine
éolienne. Si cette
production a un prix garanti de 200 € du
MWh, vous économisez 10 € du MWh, c'est
l'économie de combustible sur le
nucléaire et vous la remplacez par une
électricité qui coûte 200 €. Vous voyez
bien que on marche comme on dit sur la
tête. Donc on peut pas on peut pas
continuer comme ça. Donc et puisé
l'inspecteur général pour la sûreté
nucléaire en EDF a bien attiré et je
crois aussi le haut commissaire
l'énergie atomique du du CEA bien ont
bien attiré l'attention sur le fait que
ces yoyo sur la la production des
centrales nucléaires risque de mettre en
cause la maintenance de ces centrales
c'estàd d'aggraver de d'accroître la
nécessité de maintenance donc la
disponibilité hein réduire
l'indisponibilité et deuxièmement même
on peut se poser la question c'est ce
qu' une question qui a été posée je
crois par la la SN la RSN maintenant sur
la la sûreté des réacteurs. Donc il faut
arrêter le je pense il faut absolument
que la France impose au niveau et il y a
aucune raison de ne pas pouvoir
l'obtenir. Il y a un traité oratum, on
l'a complètement oublié dans certains
pays d'Europe et et le traité oratum
prévoit effectivement qu'on promuve
l'énergie nucléaire. C'est fondamental
quand même que la modulation du parc
nucléaire parce que aujourd'hui
effectivement quand quand il y a des
productions de d'énergie solaire ou
éolienne donc c'est le soleil et le
vent. S'il y a du soleil du vent,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On baisse. On
baisse voir on arrête parfois des des
centrales nucléaires. Alors on arrive à
le faire. c'était pas forcément prévu à
l'origine et on sait pas très bien
quelle conséquence ça effectivement il y
a il y a il y a il y a il y a a un
soupçon que c'est des conséquences quand
même sur le matériel mais on aimerait y
voir totalement clair et là on a un
organisme parlementaire qui s'appelle
l'OPEX he sur les choix scientifiques et
technologiques qui va travailler
spécifiquement sur cette questionlà la
question de la modulation du nucléaire
et ses conséquences sur le sur le les
centrales elles-mêmes et sur le le
matériel des centrales. Donc ça c'est
c'est quand même fondamental parce que
il faut savoir si on peut continuer à le
faire ou si on continue pas à le faire.
Et est-ce que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
qui est quand même une modulation aussi
assez forte si on est quasiment les
seuls dans le monde à le faire. Donc à
un moment donné, moi je veux bien qu'on
soit très très fort, très des craqus
partout, mais euh faut faut quand même
se rendre compte des conséquences que ça
peut avoir parce que ça peut coûter
aussi très très cher. Et sur le plan
économique, c'est pas justifié hein,
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure,
hein. On va produire de l'électricité à
200 € pour économiser 10 € sur le parwh
sur le clair. Je sais pas, ça pas de
sens.
qui qui qui euh se met de l'argent dans
les poches entre les deux. Mais bon,
c'est la bonne question. On parle
souvent de réchauffement climatique, de
stress hydrique. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
s'il y a pas assez de flottes en France
pour refroidir les centrales nucléaires
?
Alors, je pense que ça ça se pose
surtout pour les centrales nucléaires
qui sont en bord de fleuve ou de rivière
parce que au bord de la mer, il y aura
pas de problème. Euh c'est là où
effectivement il faut des réfrigérants
atmosphériques lorsqu'il y en a pas. Et
grâce à ces réfrigérants nocériques, je
crois qu'on règle en grande partie le
problème. C'estd que on consomme
effectivement un peu de de d'eau qui est
qui est qui est qui s'évapore bien
évidemment mais qui permet effectivement
d'éviter
beaucoup moins le réchauffement de la
rivière ou de parce que c'est ça le
problème c'est que en situation
effectivement de par exemple de
canicule, moi j'ai vécu ça he canicule
effectivement on arrive à avoir des
températures qui grimpent et à ce
moment-là on peut être coincé pour la
production d'électricité à partir de ces
ces centrales nucléaires sur euh au bord
des fleuves. Mais je pense qu'on a on a
une solution. Enfin, c'est mon point de
vue, hein. Oui. Mais
question internet. Le fait que la France
soit la centrale nucléaire et le hub de
l'Europe devrait donner un levier à
notre pays pour défendre ses intérêts.
Tout à fait. Pourquoi on le fait pas ?
Parce qu'on est en position de faiblesse
depuis un petit moment. Parce que quand
on veut imposer des choses, il faut se
montrer assez irréprochable. Et en fait,
on est loin d'être irréprochable. Ça
fait des années qu'on euh ne respecte
absolument pas les contraintes euh qui
ont été fixées au niveau européen sur le
le budget de la France, sur son ses
dépenses, ses déficits, sa dette. Donc
euh on arrive, on est les quasiment les
derniers de la classe en la matière. Et
quand vous arrivez comme le dernier de
la classe sur un aspect quand même aussi
important que les finances, vous êtes
quand même pas en position de force pour
imposer vos vues sur d'autres sujets.
Bien sûr. Alors, en plus, on a été le
couple franco-allemand qui est quand
même un des moteurs de l'Europe. Euh le
couple franco-allemand, il a été plutôt
en rade pendant pas mal d'années quand
même. Donc j'espère qu'il va redémarrer,
mais on peut pas dire qu'il était était
hyper performant. Donc tout ça, ça
explique pourquoi la France a du mal
aussi. Alors, on a on a recréé
l'alliance du nucléaire aussi pour cela
hein, pour essayer de d'avoir des alliés
dans la place et se dire voilà, on n'est
pas tout seul, il y a pas que la France
euh et ça c'est je pense que c'est une
bonne chose.
Euh Vincent, si tu veux rajouter quelque
chose, vas-y, hein. Non, non, non, mais
c'est bon. Question internet. Comment se
fait-il que les Coréens arrivent à faire
des réacteurs nucléaires pour trois fois
moins cher que EDF ? Ils ne sont pas au
salaire chinois pourtant.
Oui, parce que alors trois fois, je
dirais deux fois par rapport à je pense
au réacteur EPR check c'est de c'est
l'ord de 5000 alors que nous on est
autour de de
10000 euros du kilw. C'est ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure. Bah si vous voulez
le problème c'est surtout le la durée de
construction. Plus la durée s'allonge,
plus ça coûte cher. Effectivement, les
Coréens n'ont pas changé de de type de
réacteur. Nous, on a on a voulu faire un
EPR. Alors, il faut savoir pourquoi on a
fait un EPR. On l'a pas dit. À
l'origine, c'était une idée qui
paraissait géniale, c'était de faire un
Airbus du nucléaire avec
l'Allemagne. Alors, cet Airbus, bien
évidemment, il a été combattu dès le
départ, je dirais, par les par les verts
allemands qui
ont qui sont ingénégés à compliquer le
design de ces réacteurs. D'où les
difficultés qu'on a eu lorsqu'on a
construit le Flamville où d'ailleurs
Siemen s'est retiré du projet avant même
qu' qu'il soit commencé et on a eu des
difficultés pour construire ce ce
réacteur et même le PR2 je dirais s'il
est simplifié par rapport à le PR
reste un réacteur assez compliqué à à
réaliser. D'où effectivement les délais
qui sont plus longs que ceux qui
effectivement sont ceux qu'on trouve en
Corée en Corée du Sud. Et je parle pas
de de la Chine. J'ai dit que que la
Chine ils construisent les les réacteurs
en 5
ans. Les réacteurs coréen, je pense que
c'est un peu plus ça doit être 6 ou 7
ans. Mais voilà, la conséquence c'est le
prix. Question internet qui est un peu
longue comme le bras. essayer de nous
faire des des questions plus courtes.
Pensez aussi à nous sponsoriser sur
Tipi. C'est grâce à vous qu'on arrive à
à inviter tout le monde et à faire des
sujets aussi complexes. Question
internet. Le cuivre joue un rôle
essentiel dans le secteur de l'énergie,
notamment pour les infrastructures
électriques comme les réseaux de
distribution, les éoliennes, les
batteries des véhicules électriques.
Face à une pénurie anticipée de cuivre
d'ici 2040 liée à une demande mondiale
croissante, la France pourrait
rencontrer des obstacles majeurs dans
son développement énergétique. Comment
cette arréfaction du cuivre
risque-t-elle d'impacter le réseau
électrique et et l'économie française et
européenne ? Alors, d'abord, ce qu'il
faut dire, c'est que il y a pas que le
cuivre, hein, qui est utilisé pour les
réseaux électriques, il y a également
l'aluminium qui est un peu moins bon
conducteur que le cuivre mais qui est
quand même utilisé assez largement.
Donc, on a un matériau de substitution
avec pour les réseaux. Ensuite, au
niveau des éoliennes, bon, il y a pas il
y a pas que le cuivre, je pense qu'il y
a d'autres métaux rares qui et et ce qui
nous rend dépendant d'ailleurs de pays
comme la Chine. Ça, il faut faut le
dire, ça on le dit pas
suffisamment. Après euh voilà, euh mais
pour les réseaux, je pense pas qu'il y
ait une inquiétude majeure. Euh la seule
inquiétude, c'est que lorsque il y a des
déjà des fils en cuivre, il ils sont euh
assez souvent l'objet de vol.
notamment dans les postes électriques et
ça pose des problèmes, il faut les
remplacer. Ouais, on vit on vit une
période formidable. Je je lisais une
question et je vais essayer de la de la
reformuler de tête. Pourquoi on fait pas
du Bitcoin quand les prix sont négatifs
? Pourquoi on mine pas du Bitcoin ?
Du Bitcoin, pour quoi faire ? J'ai pas
combien compris. Quand les prix sont
négatifs, quand les prix quand les prix
Je vais essayer de retrouver la
question, je l'ai je l'ai devant moi.
Que pensez-vous de la solution pour
valoriser les surplus d'électricité en
France au lieu de les brader à des prix
négatifs à l'étranger ? Connaissez-vous
des usages innovants et localement
bénéfiques ? Je pense par exemple au
minage de Bitcoin sur surplus ou à
d'autres solutions comme la production
d'hydrogène ou le stockage thermique ?
Il y en a d'autres selon vous avec un
vrai bilan positif ? Alors, sur les
Bitcoin, c'est en fait le problème des
data centers parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir que les Bitcoin, c'est euh ça
consomme également euh énormément de
d'électricité, hein. Euh c'est la la
technique qui qui veut ça. C'est-à-dire
que il y a plusieurs ordinateurs qui
communiquent en permanence entre eux et
qui garantissent
effectivement le le ces ces cet argent
qui qui circule.
Donc à mon avis, on peut effectivement
les Bitcoin vont vont peut-être surtout
ce qu'on appelle le mining va permettre
de créer effectivement des de nouveaux
besoins en électricité y compris en
France. Mais ça reste à mon avis limité.
Je pas on parlait pas de de nouveaux
besoins là. Là on parlait quand il y a
du surplu par exemple que on va
stabiliser le réseau faire faire du
Bitcoin derrière si vous voulez Bitcoin
a besoin de l'électricité en permanence.
Non mais pas Oui mais là là donc ça
répond pas ça répond pas à la demande.
C'est que lorsqu'il y a des surplus
d'électricité, on appuie sur un bouton
et ça mine. Pardon ? On appuie sur un
bouton et ça mine. Oui. Oui. Mais il y
en a il faut il faut que cette
électricité soit disponible en
permanence pour les bitcoins. C'est ça
le problème. C'est pas uniquement quand
on a on a des surplus siolz. Et ensuite
alors l'autre sujet qui est évoqué c'est
l'hydrogène. Alors faire de l'hydrogène
parce que l'idée effectivement c'est de
stocker de l'électricité sous forme
d'hydrogène. Et puis ensuite une fois
qu'on a stocké cette électricité sous
forme d'hydrogène, on on produit avec
l'hydrogène à nouveau de l'électricité.
Le rendement, je vais vous le dire,
c'est de 25 %. C'estd vous injectez 4
kWh en amont et vous vous raccordez vous
vous vous récupérez 1 kWh vous rendez
compte ? C'est pas possible hein. Donc
c'est c'est une vue de l'esprit de faire
des choses pareilles hein. Ça coûte
beaucoup trop cher hein. Et et alors qui
plus si vous envisagez de produire de
l'hydrogène avec des énergies
renouvelables intermittentes ? La
conséquence comme c'est la production
n'est pas à niveau constant, vous avez
un rendement des électrolyseurs qui
chutent au moins de moitié. Alors déjà,
c'est cher de produire des de
l'hydrogène avec une une production
constante, par exemple à partir du
nucléaire qui à mon avis le meilleur
moyen de produire de l'hydrogène
décarboné. Si vous la produisez avec des
énergies renouvelables intermittentes,
ça marche pas quoi. Comment vous
produisez de l'hydrogène avec du
nucléaire ? Pardon ? Comment vous
prodigez ? Vous produisez vous euh avec
des électrodisseurs, vous produisez. Et
les platinoïdes, tout va bien ? Ils sont
disponibles. Pardon ? Les platinoïdes
pour les électrolyses, ils sont
disponibles. Il va pas y avoir un
problème avec les platinoïdes ?
Non, je enfin je ça
je vous voyez de quoi je Ah ben moi moi
non là là je suis je suis dépassé là.
Oui. Question pour monsieur le sénateur.
Non non mais dites-moi, j'ai pas bien
compris. Cathéoïdes. Les platinoïdes.
Ah, les platinoïdes. Ah oui, pour faire
des électrolyseurs. Voulez
dire pour faire des électrolyseurs les
platinoïes.
C'est ça. C'est
Oui. Bon, je pense que il y a une bonne
disponibilité. Écoutez, je je je peux
pas vous répondre de manière précise,
mais apparemment oui, on peut de toute
manière si vous voulez. Le problème des
électrolyseurs, c'est que ça coûte cher
quoi, hein. Ça coûte cher. Alors,
produire de l'hydrogène et après
utiliser l'hydrogène tel quel, pourquoi
pas ? Mais produire de l'hydrogène pour
pouvoir stocker de l'électricité et
reproduire de l'électricité à partir de
l'hydrogène avec une pile à combustible,
je vous dis, le rendement est de 25 % au
total. 60 % pour l'électrolyseur et 50 %
pour le la pile à combustible. Donc vous
retrouvez le cas vous voyez c'est
multiplication par 4 en quelque sorte du
prix de l'électricité donc ça marche pas
quoi. Vincent question pour vous
monsieur le sénateur pour vous qu'est-ce
qui bloque l'action dans nos
institutions malgré tous ces rapports
qui sont utilisés pour allumer les
cheminées
? Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce qui bloque ?
C'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure,
c'est que notre démocratie fonctionne
mal. Si notre démocratie fonctionnait
bien, effectivement le le pouvoir, il
devrait être aux élus. Moi je je trouve
qu'en démocratie, ce sont les élus qui
doivent avoir le pouvoir et aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas. Donc effectivement
faut revoir pas mal de choses dans le
fonctionnement de nos institutions.
Euh alors on a on a l'impression tout
est figé qu'on considère que que le
système qui était mis en place par le
général de Gaulle à une certaine époque
et par rapport à sa personnalité et au
fonctionnement de de l'époque euh il
peut fonctionner comme ça le vitamernam.
Moi je je le pense pas. Je je pense
qu'il faudrait revoir quand même
nettement euh le fonctionnement de nos
démocraties et nous permettre alors sur
plein de sujets hein parce que je disais
tout à l'heure qu'il fallait de la
transparence. Si si on veut de la
transparence et de l'information, il
faut changer pas mal de choses parce que
même les parlementaires n'ont pas cette
transparence et cette information. Même
quand on la demande, on l'a pas. Donc
tout part déjà de là et ensuite dans les
circuits de décision effectivement il y
a il y aurait pas mal de choses à faire.
Bon voilà c'est c'est un peu difficile
de développer là en de temps trois
mouvements mais voilà c'est question
internet. La France dispose des
premières réserves de gaz de chiste et
d'hydrogon. Oui d'hydrogène pardon.
Pourquoi d'hydrogène naturel ? Oui,
pourquoi ne développe fait pas de faute
quand vous faites les questions parce
que après moi quand je les lis, je passe
pour
un Pourquoi ne développons pas ces
énergies de manière propre et surtout
non polluante afin d'être indépendant ?
l'énergie est existentielle. Donc le gaz
de chiste, l'hydrogène.
Alors l'hydrogène, ce qu'on appelle
l'hydrogène blanc qui effectivement
qu'on trouve souvent lié à du charbon en
dessous des des
des du des mines de charbon. App ça nous
ailleux, pardon. Le Grisou, c'est ça ?
Euh, c'est pas le Grisou, hein, c'est de
l'hydrogène. C'est-à-dire que c'est
c'est Alors, on ce qu'on sait pas, c'est
sil y a il y en a beaucoup quoi. Il y a
des Il semblerait qu'on ait de
l'hydrogène blanc notamment dans l'est
de la France, là où il y a des là où il
y avait des mines et peut-être aussi
dans le nord. Mais on ne sait pas, on n'
pas évalué à mon à mon ma connaissance
hein, je tiens à le dire, la quantité
que représente ça représente en
hydrogène blanc.
Euh bon à mon avis c'est une et son coup
d'extraction c'est une piste à à
regarder quoi. C'est c'est moi je pense
que ce qui ce qui qui fait pas qui a
fait pas beaucoup de mal quand même
c'est le principe de précaution dans la
constitution. Oui bien sûr. Ça ça fait
partie des choses qui à mon avis
n'auraient jamais dû être faites parce
que on on a bloqué un certain nombre de
recherches ou de d'expériences et autres
qui nous bloquent. Euh alors qu'on fasse
attention, je suis d'accord, mais qu'on
mette de façon constitutionnelle un
principe de précaution systématique,
c'est c'est assez mortel. Je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable. Ça, je partage
ce point de vue. Ça c'est c'est sûr. Je
me fais l'avocat du diable. Euh on voit
aux États-Unis des nappes fréatiques
contaminées avec des gaz. On voit les
riverins ouvrir leur robinets avec des
flammes qui sortent de leur robinets. On
voit des animaux qui tombent
malades. Nous, on a déjà du mal à avoir
de l'eau minérale non
filtrée. Alors, si on commence à faire
du gaz de chiste, alors est-ce que entre
ces excès et ce qu'on ce qu'on pourrait
faire en France, est-ce qu'il y a pas un
juste milieu quoi ? C'est une réponse de
sénateur ça. C'est une réponse de
sénateur et de de personnes qui
cherchent un équilibre et recherche
l'intérêt général. L'intérêt général,
c'est pas de se bloquer sur toutes les
recherches. Voilà. Après, c'est pas de
faire n'importe quoi non plus, de
laisser tout le monde faire n'importe
quoi et dans n'importe quel sens. Alors,
aux États-Unis, c'est un peu particulier
parce que vous avez des États qui sont
euh qui qui qui ont des politiques assez
différentes les uns des autres, hein. Il
faut pas croire que les États-Unis,
c'est un bloc, un monobloc. On en
parlait tout à l'heure et c'est vous que
je regardais mais il faut que je regarde
aussi la caméra. Mais euh c'est vrai que
que il y a des États qui ont des
politiques très différentes et du coup
euh c'est vrai que parfois il y a il y a
aussi un certain laxisme et qu'on laisse
faire un peu n'importe quoi. Donc il
faut il faut aussi que là-dessus euh
mais entre cette position de laxisme et
la position de dire on empêche tout
parce que il y a un principe de
précaution qui est là et qui qui nous
empêche de de faire il y a un juste
milieu il y a un juste milieu qui à mon
avis on n pas trouvé encore. questions
internet et ça il y a il y a énormément
de questions et on va on va arrêter d'en
poser parce que ça fait déjà 2h24 que
nous sommes en
direct. Question internet. Comment
expliquez-vous que le rendement réel des
EPR soit systématiquement inférieur aux
prévisions initiales malgré les
améliorations techniques apportées par
rapport au REP de génération précédente
? Vous pouvez répéter la question ? Oui,
répétez la question par ça je répète la
question. Comment expliquez-vous que le
rendement réel des EPR soit
systématiquement inférieur aux
prévisions initial malgré les
améliorations techniques apportées par
rapport au REP de génération précédente
? Oui. Alors à mon avis, d'abord euh
Flamville est un prototype he je parle
de de Flamandville. J'ai expliqué
pourquoi on a eu des difficultés pour
construire Flamville, hein. C'est à mon
avis c'est à l'origine du projet. Et
bien évidemment, il y a eu une perte de
compétence au niveau de la grande maison
EDF du fait qu'on a arrêté la
construction de réacteur du nucléaire
pendant plusieurs années, hein. Et donc,
il y a beaucoup d'ingénieurs compétents
qui sont partis à la retraite. Donc,
effectivement, on a eu beaucoup de mal.
Ensuite le PR2, on peut espérer quand
même que on aura tiré le retour
d'expérience de le PR de Flamandville,
mais aussi le le PR finlandais et même
des EPR qui ont été réalisés en Chine et
en Grande-Bretagne, hein. Et donc on
peut espérer, il empêche
qu'effectivement le design prévoit
effectivement une complexité qui est
sans doute supérieure à celle qu'on peut
retrouver dans les anciens réacteurs
réacteurs de du plan Mesmer et des
réacteurs qui sont construits ailleurs
dans le monde. Donc ça c'est
effectivement un choix qui a été fait et
ce choix là bon il se il se discute bien
évidemment hein mais c'est souvent ce ce
complexité est liée à un besoin de
niveau de sûreté qui est supérieur.
C'est souvent ça que alors fact checking
contre Merlin. Le minage du Bitcoin est
flexible. Il peut s'arrêter
instantanément en cas de tension et
reprendre en surplus. C'est ce qui se
fait déjà au Texas et ça stabilise le
réseau source. Tant mieux, je la prends
mais c'est pas effectivement. Et les
dernières questions pour monsieur le
sénateur Vincent. En 2027, le chauffage
thermique des particulers va être
assujetti au marché du carbone avec
comme conséquence un enchérissement de
la facture. N'allons-nous pas vers une
nouvelle vague de gilets jaune ? Si si,
c'est c'est ces contraintes que l'on que
l'on por que l'on pose sur pas mal de
sujets, notamment sur le sujet de
l'habitat, c'est euh c'est c'est
explosif. Et c'est explosif parce que je
pense qu'on veut aller trop vite avec de
bonnes intentions en fait. On veut aller
trop vite et euh les gens n'ont pas le
temps ni les moyens non plus toujours de
de s'adapter. Euh c'est des sujets euh
sur lesquels on prend des décisions sans
recul et sans vraiment étude d'impact.
Ça, j'insiste beaucoup sur les études
d'impact moi quand les gens qui
m'écoutent un petit peu parce que comme
les a des feux, c'est ça ?
Oui. Les feu, il y a rien. Il y a rien.
Écoutez, vous savez là là on va on va
sans doute débattre de la fin de vie.
Moi, je je suis en train de regarder les
histoires de euh de d'étude d'impact
justement sur les soins palliatifs. Mais
en fait, vous apercevez que les études
d'impact sont très pauvres. on a rien.
Donc en fait, on on légifère avec des
études d'impact qui sont là pour la
forme et euh et c'est vrai sur plein de
sujets. Donc sur les sujets
environnementaux, je dis pas qu'il faut
il faut s'arrêter, il faut pas
s'arrêter, mais il faut fixer des
objectifs réalistes et atteignables pour
tout le monde, y compris pour euh pour
tous les propriétaires et les gens qui
ont pas forcément beaucoup de moyens et
à qui on demande des contraintes
considérables. Donc c'est vrai, c'est
vrai que moi je je partage ce souci
d'essayer de de faire avec les gens et
de façon réaliste. Je vous lis des
questions mais on va pas y répondre
parce qu'on aura pas le temps. Il y a
des questions. Quel avenir pour la
fusion nucléaire et sous quel délai la
géothermie et le solaire thermique
production d'eau chaude domestique
sont-elles des solutions pertinentes en
France ? La fin du siècle. Oui. Un petit
mot. C'est la fin du siècle. La fusion
du la fusion c'est au mieux la fin du
siècle. Au mieux la fin du siècle. On
arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Voilà. Est-ce que vous avez trois livres
à conseiller à notre communauté ?
Monsieur Merlin écoutez moi je je suis
un fanat de Jul Verne et donc je peux je
peux même dire je suis un collectionneur
de Jul Vernein et donc mes livres
préférés c'est effectivement les les
romans de Jul Verne en particulier les
plus
connus à milieu sous la sous la terre
milieu sous la mer pas sous la terre
excusez-moi
et puis d'autres qui sont un peu il y a
Michel Strogof qui qui est très
Il y a eu récemment d'ailleurs un film
sur euh donc voilà c'est c'est ce que je
je dirai en ce qui me vient tout de
suite à l'esprit.
Et moi les livres les livres qui m'ont
beaucoup marqué. Alors le premier c'est
Raymond Aaron. Les mémoires de Raymond
Aaron. C'est compliqué, c'est dur.
Parfois il faut relire deux trois fois
un certain certains chapitres mais il y
a du fond. il y a du fond et c'est
quelqu'un qui était euh qui était qui
était un peu à l'opposé de ce qui se
faisait à l'époque en terme de
philosophie, d'intellectuel et qui euh
ne n'a pas hésité, qui a été courageux,
qui a défendu toujours ses idées. Et euh
moi, j'aime beaucoup Raymond Aaron et ce
livre des mémoires m'a toujours
passionné. le premier homme de Camu
aussi. Euh premier homme, c'était son
dernier roman inachevé mais qui décrit
vraiment euh ce qu'il a vécu et avec les
les la qualité d'écriture de Camu. Et
puis le dernier, ça a rien à voir, c'est
Jérôme Fourquet, l'archipel français
parce que Jérôme Fourquet a rassemblé un
beaucoup de données très intéressantes
sur l'évolution de la société française
sur les 50 dernières années. Et je pense
que ça peut expliquer en partie les
problèmes qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui et
les perspectives que l'on doit avoir
tous ensemble d'essayer de voir comment
la société française qui a perdu quand
même un certain nombre d'institutions,
qu'on les aime ou qu'on les aime pas
mais il y avait des institutions, il y
avait l'église, il y avait le parti
communiste, il y avait il y avait un
certain nombre d'institutions il y a 50
ans qui rassemblaient quand même
beaucoup de Français et aujourd'hui on
en a plus tellement. parti politique, il
y a plus grand monde. Euh chacun vit
avec les siens, les communautés, on
s'est donc on s'est archipélisé. Comment
on fait ? On refait nation. En fait,
c'est une des questions centrales quand
même de la France aujourd'hui. C'est
dire comment on arrive à se retrouver
tous ensemble pour refaire nation. Et ça
c'est pas simple mais le livre est très
éclairant sur beaucoup de sujets et
quand on veut quand même comprendre un
peu l'évolution de la société française,
je pense qu'il mérite d'être lui. Alors
façon comme je je vous sous la main pour
la dernière question, on donnera ensuite
la parole à André. Un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Je pense qu'il faut qu'il s'intéresse à
la chose publique. Il faut qu'ils
s'investissent dans dans la chose
publique. Il y a trop peu de personnes
qui s'y intéressent. Euh on a besoin de
de gens compétents qui qui ont envie euh
euh d'aller euh d'aller de l'avant et
qui peuvent apporter euh notamment avec
leur expérience professionnelle euh des
choses qu'on n'a pas forcément dans le
milieu politique. Ce qui est dramatique
dans le milieu politique, c'est les gens
qui n'ont fait que de la politique toute
leur vie et qui ne sortent pas de ce
milieu. Donc il faut on a besoin de 109
et de de personnes qui s'y intéressent.
Et donc euh c'est un conseil, c'est
presque une demande. Mais c'est vrai que
moi j'aimerais qu'il y ait beaucoup plus
de jeunes qui qui s'engagent dans la vie
politique et dans la vie publique.
André, je partage assez bien cet avis
mais j'ajouterai en plus que les jeunes
générations devraient effectivement
croire au progrès technique et donc
s'investir dans ces domaines là autant
qu'ils peuvent le faire. hein, je crois
et je pense en particulier aux femmes
euh aux jeunes femmes qui doivent
effectivement euh ne pas hésiter à
entreprendre une carrière dans le
domaine technique et notamment une
carrière d'ingénieur pour ce celles qui
sont capables de le faire. On manque
d'ingénieur et je pense que les femmes
peuvent porter beaucoup dans ce domaine.
Je trouve que j'ai une petite fille donc
je pense à elle en particulier en disant
cela. On l'embrasse
aussi André Merlin, Vincent, merci,
merci à vous. Merci de cette vidéo.
[Musique]